alrighty a very good morning and a warm
welcome in joining us for the
president's design award 2023 Juris
Forum this is jointly organized by a
design Singapore Council and the urban
Redevelopment Authority and is part of
the PDA creating a better world by
Design Series so my name is Julian ayal
and I am your MC for today some of the
most influential names in design have
gathered in Singapore for a week for
this PDA 2023 jury session to select the
recipients of the nation's highest
design honor this recipients will be
announced at the award ceremony at the
Asana in July so we have honored to have
our distinguished jurors join us as part
of a panel here today unfortunately our
speakers Mr Christoph ingenhoven and Mr
Mayan's song will not be able to join us
today so we do apologize for any
inconvenience cause and we appreciate
your understanding
for boa and Sia members there will be
six CPD points accredited to members who
have registered and stayed until the end
of this forum so please do stay all the
way today uh for the to fill in a survey
form with your details to qualify for
your CPD points throughout this session
you may also send in your questions for
the Q a segment you'll see the QR code
over there please feel free to scan it
and uh you might just have your
questions answered during the Q a
segment later on as well
and for now without further Ado it is my
pleasure to invite architect yup Levy
group director of the architecture and
Urban Design Group at Urban
Redevelopment authority to give her
welcome remarks architect yup please
[Applause]
good morning distinguished speakers
friends and colleagues ladies and
gentlemen
um welcome to the president design award
Jerry's father and we are very happy to
have everybody here in Era today my
young son likes to you know come explore
you know the city Gallery he thinks I
have a very fun job you know holding
I'll be playing with models you know
doing sketchings drawings and I
explained to him that you know we have
to form Tech teams we have to work
across and get everybody to come
together and aim to design our city to
be a great place to live for and play
end well today we are living in a world
where you know challenges as you know
are becoming more complex than ever and
design has a crucial role to play in
addressing these issues and the theme of
this forum is called you know creating a
better world by Design and this could
not have been more timely and relevant
you know for our times so we are very
honored you know today to have some of
the most inspiring and knowledgeable
individuals you know across the
different disciplines to share their
insights on a sustainable human
uh sustainable cities and Human
Experience designed so on the macro
level as a city right is beyond about
you know Carbon emission saving energy
it is also about how the buildings are
designed to come together the spaces
between the buildings and how people
move through the spaces right on the
individual and Community level it is
about you know how do we design spaces
that we love spaces that will inspire us
and also meeting our needs you know and
and basically the places that we call
home so therefore you know through the
exchange today we hope to gain
understanding on how we can create
different
quality spaces you know that that we
have for us
so just as my young son is learning you
know new things about the world every
day even myself you know as a designer
and architect you know we re-learned we
Embrace new tools we work and
collaborate and stick up Partnerships
you know with the different expertise uh
you know across the different fields of
experts so I hope to know will embrace
the opportunity this morning to share to
learn and exchange you know between the
different designers and collectively
together we create we can and we hope to
create a better world for us thank you
thank you
thank you very much architect yup I'll
now like to invite Miss Don Lim
executive director of design Singapore
Council to give her welcome remarks as
well miss Lindley is
good morning everyone
professionally I am known as Don Lim
executive director of the dying
Singapore Council it's a mouthful
but outside my professional role I wear
another hat
I am simply Dawn
I'm a daughter I'm a caregiver to my
late mother who was a stroke patient and
wheelchair bound for more than a decade
and every time we wanted to go out of
the house
I would have to meticulously plan our
route to find the most accessible way
we have a great public transport system
but public transport for us was out of
the question because trying to get from
our home to the nearest bus stop or MRT
station is an optical course in itself
if you're in a wheelchair
so we had to drive
and most of the time we ended up in our
malls to escape the Heat and the warmth
outside
this was also a time before our
extensive Park connectors came up
if you've ever been to our malls and and
all of you some of you have designed it
some of you all of you have visited it
um especially our Heartland malls
the most direct way anywhere inside the
mall
is actually the least convenient and
least accessible for somebody in a
wheelchair
the lift Lobby is typically hidden at
the back in a corner of the building
after you navigate narrow corridors past
tons of shops
try going to the bathroom
we've been in situations where the
handicapped bathroom is further than the
regular bathroom
and we finally get there
we find that it's locked
because the mall operator wants to
prevent unnecessary usage extra cleaning
or abuse of use
you'd be surprised how many people steal
a smoke break inside the handicapped
toilets
this week during the PDA
interviews and judging
someone shared a story that it's
impossible to cross
from Grand Hyatt
to Lido or without place
if you're not mobile
think about it
that huge Junction of Orchard Road and
Scott's Road
for most of us able-bodied people we
simply just go underground we navigate
that huge Subterranean Network that's
Orchard MRT station and let me pop up on
one side on the other side of that
Junction
but for someone in a wheelchair
that's impossible
and there's also a why for 10 years my
mother and I never made that Crossing
but it doesn't have to be this way
we can and we should Aspire for a better
Society a better place
a better Human Experience
I have since experienced some
wonderfully accessible places
where it's a delight for somebody in a
wheelchair because the space was
designed with them in mind from the
start
and I wish my mother was still around to
enjoy the extensive parks and green
spaces that we have today because I'm
sure that would really have helped in
her palliative Journey
her lived experience and my experience
as her caregiver
is just a small sample of the Myriad of
needs that the people have out there and
that all of you as designers face every
day
and I think it's precisely why today's
panel discussion topics are designing
for sustainable cities and designing for
The Human Experience is so relevant and
so pertinent
and it's not just about designing a city
for the mobility challenge
it's about designing a place that we
call home as Libby had shared
it's a place where we as residents enjoy
a high quality of life
we have access to spaces Services
products
things that create joy things that
create a sense of belonging
I think we can do better and that is my
hope
and that is my belief
we are very privileged to have six of
our jurors here today from many
different countries and I hope in their
stories that they share with you you
will be inspired as well to create a
better world for generations to come
I wish you an engaging session ahead and
I entrust our city and our home in your
hands thank you
thank you very much Miss Lim as
mentioned we have a lot of design
thought leaders in our space here today
also we have a packed Auditorium so
before we begin our first panel I want
to invite everybody to take a group
photo together this is including all of
our audience as well so whenever our
photographer is ready everybody put on
your best Mouse people at the back
you're going to be seen as well yeah so
small as wide as you can
we're just going to do a big group
photograph right now
[Music]
he had to ask can I get a fun shot
very cute thank you so much ladies and
gentlemen that was a great start to our
Friday morning right here and of course
with that I saw like very cute know some
of your hearts different kind of Hearts
all around
we will be beginning our session for
today the very first panel today we will
be discussing on the topic of Designing
for sustainable cities and high density
urban areas in Singapore and overseas
such as Hong Kong Japan and Thailand so
our first Speaker would be Miss kochakon
boracom founder and CEO of land process
porous City Network in Thailand as well
as jury member of the design panel
a little bit more about Miss culture
carnivore.com otherwise known as Koch
she is a Thai Landscape Architects who
work on productive public spaces
tackling climate change in dense urban
areas she created the first critical
green infrastructure for Bangkok at the
Chula Longhorn Centenary Park and her
works also include the tammasat urban
farm rooftop the biggest Urban farming
Rooftop in Asia as well as the first
Bridge park across the river in any
world Capital the ciao prayer Sky Park
coach receive a un Global Climate action
award from the unfccc in 2020 and has
been recognized in numerous lists
including the time 100 next list in 2019
the BBC 100 women list in 2020 and the
Bloomberg green 30 for 2020 list she has
also been recognized by time as one of
15 women fighting against climate change
so with that introduction I would like
to invite coach please
[Applause]
thank you everyone I'm probably not
using the podium because otherwise you
always see my eyes so
um sustainable City first question for
me is for who
is it for you or for me or for un we
actually have a very different
um
experience and definition and today I'm
going to share my this is Bangkok where
you guys love to hang out and go for
food and
great experience for tourists but it's
such a worst place for people to live
there not to just travel there so this
is how flat we are and this is an urban
setting with a lot of concrete
architecture
so when we think about landscape we
always think about okay you work in the
planter or you do some leftover space
from whatever the development but I just
want you to understand that land is
actually Underground
that the whole city
or the architecture is actually placed
on and the land is not even we are flat
but the real line is not flat it
actually has its own Dynamics it's
three-dimension beneath it this is
who we were as sylvanians of the east or
maybe Bangkok of the West yes
and this is my experience during the
flooding and this is my favorite toy
from my dad who created for me but this
is the same experience in 2011 with the
same word flooding
so you can see that this is Bangkok we
are just right in the whole Watershed is
the whole water is gonna have to drain
there but through 2011 you can see how
much water we have and how we keep
Bangkok from getting wet you can see
that that part is not blue so we flocked
other people who's Thai as well and this
is yes they are Thai and this is how we
have to confront with unexpected rain
like it doesn't fall into like the dams
that we built but it's Fallen to like
the urban setting and this is the sea
level rise crazy we have no boundary and
you you can see that Bangkok starts to
have our own beach now like Phuket
because it's coming closer and closer
so this is where you want to touch
Bangkok boundary you have to go into the
boat and actually travel there and this
is how
fast we go
and 15 minutes of rainfall this is how
life is and you have fun having friends
and
don't worry about us we're very
resilient this is how we adapt
it's nothing not a problem with the
flooding but the problem is about Urban
infrastructure that doesn't allow us to
adapt
so right now this is like right now it's
a copying burning
um seasons and you can see that this is
not only from us it's from Cambodia like
it's they burn and the wind flow through
us and the Myanmar apart so it's just a
trans boundary impact that we're living
in and 2 pm 2.55
and this is the impact of the triple
impact of climate change to Bangkok
nowadays so 10 years later it's going to
be worse and worse
so I think we are at the point or adapt
or die
so in 2012 I won a competition and to
build the first part in 30 years
some of you haven't been born yet 30
years or all of you have been born
so I'm trying to find a young face but
yeah
so this is like
um right in downtown Bangkok and the
land costs a thousand million U.S
crazy expensive line and they want to be
another shopping mall but do we really
need that
so be flat I
um inclined the whole park to collect
safe drops of rain and equipped with
rainwater tank green roof retention pond
at work as one system
uh I know all this work but just the way
we implemented with such a limited land
this is I think how we can be adapt as
Thai like in every corner of this park
you can see people use because it's the
first one is the line so expensive and
we fought so hard to have this piece the
Wetland the the incline the whole park
can actually help the drain and also the
flooding to double the size when
when yes
and the bike for people to really feel
what's the water today by the exercise
so it was lovely with the change so it's
the part that is designed to flood
and people will know that we can leave
it flood again
and it's got so many awards and people
love it youngster people which is like
this is the first inclined part we can
have a concert here
and and yeah the tree goes and perfect
and Mr Antonio gutorres the number one
climate change of the world figure came
to give the support to the local
designer such an honor
and they even keep this example to to be
part of the the undp the urban ecosystem
based solution
so okay I'm gonna go fast but this is
how we are even how rich you are or how
many GDP you made but during the covet
we put our we has been put down on the
same floor
and I think in terms of the food
Securities and many the poverty problems
actually happen even you have 7-Eleven
or Bangkok but it's actually if you
don't have money how could you get food
and within the covet pandemic we are
here together
so this is um open during the pandemic
is the biggest Urban Rooftop in Asia so
I'm actually far harboring An Architect
no I'm skating we work together
so we work at par to having this
architecture create from the problem of
the rooftop that normally people don't
easily access and how is all this web
space on top can be part of the food
security system and how all this thing
can slow down the runoff great food for
the campus using solar roof to pump up
all this retention water and just drain
down and you get food so and then
is kind of like all in one Everything at
Once kind of solution and we need that
we don't need this there yeah just make
Recreation for people but we need all
that possibility because we don't have
enough land and we want to exist here
Bangkok has to be in the map so we have
to really be more creative on the
limitation that we have but not asking
for something that we couldn't afford
so this is Young's generation is soda
runoff 20 times and create your food and
of course answer the much public space
that we need
and it was fun it's the first time that
the landscape architect got the first
year the Year best from The Architects
award and I think we need to work more
together a landscape can be concepts of
many things we're not working in the
plant we're working on the land so
that's the depth of the work
yes
I'm sorry architect but yes I know
um this is
um Venice of the east of Bangkok of the
West
um this is who we are but this is who we
are right now this is only about this
let me know the time now I yeah when
it's five minutes so this is who we are
as a city
and you can see how bad we treat our own
body thinking about the landscape as a
um your body you we are we put something
dirty in our vein the blood wind caught
and we cut it out and how could you
survive as a living being the city is
not us it's actually have its own life
it's half it's 3D um Quality the
underground water the rains and this is
how it hasn't been connected and this is
me
um working with many Governors this is a
previous governor try like yeah we have
to clean this
enable to survive
our city
so right now it's open last year it's a
lot of thinking like how we're gonna
reconnect the canal that we disconnected
and reclaim the natural infrastructure
and we picked up this is right on CBD
Saturn
um
so you have to connect the the canal the
connect to the river using the
Wastewater and pump it back to the
canals and make it more livable for
people because this is so smelly and
it's the most dirtiest Canal but it's
actually right downtown CBD Bangkok you
guys probably don't enjoy this part you
just go to massage and all these little
things but this is
um and try to make it nice for for us as
well so this is I just go quickly
and it's so important but it's still
ongoing and with the new governor we
have to reconvince him to complete the
whole project
so I this is the Bangkok China Wall
between canals and people because when
people drunk and filled out maybe the
tourists get killed from just get drunk
and they say okay we need to build the
China wall so people safe but the
problem of that is just like the life
after this
um
separation is actually create the worst
living and these homeless people love it
which is great they are part of the city
but this is not the place why we're not
designed for this
so this is normal section but think
about how we have to go through all this
department to oh this is not my I
couldn't touch this is not I couldn't
touch
um the policy thing is very different
how yeah this is the most photogenic
picture
so this is uh
it's a lot and it's not like
um I envy you that you have government
taking care of this thing but for us we
have to make government who are in The
Silo of like
and break them down like this oh my God
it's it's a lot of work so there's a lot
of like meetings and things that we have
to go through and eventually we can take
off the Bangkok China Wall that's kind
of
living right how the sustained city
I have three minutes oh my God okay
[Laughter]
okay I go quick and I stop when I have
to stop
so yeah this is how we supposed to use
Canal as place of human being and
luckily that it's got a award from un
habitat like
so the proof to the city to the mayor to
the governor to whoever that this is
worth it of international recognition
with all this small action in a big city
this is a leftover structure and you can
see that it's 40 years ago we built this
thing imagine that we're gonna be the
first nation to have the sky train cross
over the river even before Singapore and
then 40 years later it's still not
coming
it's called somebody else so what can we
do with this structure so we create a
pedestrian bridge it's the first one
this is our team
this is how prom it is and it's so
narrow it's a meters with um 200 so
we create this Landmark Park so come
back and visit this part don't come in
at noon right it's so hot so the sunset
and sunrise will be the the perfect
place so we reuse what we our vision has
been
um there for 40 years and we become the
first public park is connect the
existing Tupac first one in in any
capital of the world because we think it
40 years ago
[Laughter]
yes but it's just it's a possibility for
people to live in Happily and I think
that's why the design have to be the to
pay the very important part and
yes
and I think okay one minute I'm not only
working for those who have budgets and
real clients or many of this doesn't
have real clients we have to fight for
the fundings and things but
also this is the big things in Thailand
the right um the speed train that's
going to be in around the city oh not
another Nation
and they have to displace poor people or
who doesn't have right to stay in a
place or informal settlement or
some people and all these things then
they have these 400 million Baht budget
and say okay it's flood let's do them
but we have to tell them what's happened
if they receive this money you cannot
flood other people's more you want to
flood your neighbors
and you're going to flood yourself
because
this is what it's gonna look like many
of them who's who doesn't pay us but
have the right impact to all this
decision and design need to know and we
again so hard that this is not the right
solution why you have to spend
I just realized that Thailand is very
rich country
but just the money doesn't go in the
right place
so
and this is Jakarta and we're just like
do we want to be like that
time out okay on this is do we want to
be like this and this is in New Orleans
the US and I just kept the lecture at um
Harvard University and say I'm sorry we
don't want to be like you and
and okay let me come back to our
Southeast Asian country we are at rest
and no man is an island and we are in
this together so if our home is at risk
what can we do Singapore would not
better off with this city in the nature
because we are neighbor thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much coach has an amazing
presentation clearly singaporeans do all
do the same things in Thailand uh
hopefully on your next trip there you'll
be able to see the country in a
different light
so our second speaker for today will be
the co-founder and executive director of
design trust Hong Kong she's also a jury
member of the design panel Miss Marissa
Yu so Marissa Yu is the co-founder and
executive director of the design trust
initiative that supports creative and
research content related to Hong Kong
and the greater Bay Area she has been
instrumental in shaping the growth of
the NGO since 2014 and has created and
conceptualized the design trust Futures
Studio program Marissa is also an
architect and founding partner of SQ a
multi-disciplinary architecture and
research Design Studio that actively
integrates culture community art and
Technology
Marissa's work and ridings have been
published in A.D doma's China mit's
threshold and Architectural record
amongst others she has also spoken at
numerous Global platforms including tedx
at the Chinese University of Hong Kong
bodw UNESCO forum and Harvard's Asia GSD
conference
she has thought at London's
architectural Association Parsons
University of Hong Kong and the School
of Architecture at cuhk Marissa is also
an AIA member hkia associate served on
the board of advisors for rthk and was
formerly a board member of the Hong Kong
ambassadors of design so with all of
those achievements we're very glad to
have her here today can I invite Marissa
please
[Applause]
hard to follow your very amazing work
um okay
let's see
I know I have 15 minutes but um maybe
just to hold our thought on the role of
architecture designers and participation
in our city it's a collective
willpower to make change it's been of I
have to be on as a very difficult last
few years in our city this is my first
official trip outside of Hong Kong but
it's also the willpower and the
commitment of collective communities
coming together and then I think this is
something
um to to keep in mind the backdrop of
what sustainability is it's not so much
about just um Matrix The Greening
reaching kpis but also involving the
community in that process so what I'm
going to just share today is a very dear
project to our foundation but also as a
citizen to question our role and our
civic responsibility in the production
of any culture and City
I have a very colorful
rainbow
D for design trust our branding actually
used to be very deep blue but in the
last few years just thinking about
psychology of color representation of
color really makes us think about the
notion of aspiration and hope through a
apolitical and non-political environment
how do we bring that together through
design and
um the the kind of case study project
I'll probably
put forward is how do we involve our
community how do we test with pilot
projects
and still Embrace failure along the way
but also along that change mindset of
ourselves and beyond our own community
so this is just some case studies to
share exploration and the notion of
smallness to harness bigger change so a
little bit different cost amazing work
and I have been admiring a lot of the
kind of big moves and gestures of
urbanism and sometimes when you look at
the end product you don't realize how
much effort how much empowering how much
discussions and stakeholder management
it takes to make change so I really hope
this is something quite special to share
so in 2007 the non-profit Hong Kong
Ambassador design was founded to really
encourage and support and Advance
competency but also question expertise
and there was a moment of time where in
2013 we were doing a lot of from 2007 to
2013 a lot of really exciting big
gestural projects I would say very
exciting public space transformation
but also what is the question of kind of
deep rigorous research so this is how we
founded the the community platform
um to benefit a kind of a younger
generation of
um really talented students formally
when I was more involved in Academia but
also this kind of rising urgency to
question how can I own a home what is
the question of ability to build
research and and transformation of one's
career as a young architect or designer
but also have an engaging discussion on
the global platform of where design can
actually participate
so fast forward from 2014 or to all the
way to now
our program our non-profit organization
has provided support to about 523
designer grantee mentee fellows
um and in 2017 there was Epiphany where
we realized the only way we can impact
mindset is actually to produce more
experimental pilot projects so it came
up with this um kind of community Think
Tank program called design trust future
Studios where it's both mentorship
mentorship looking at Urgent topics
having a lot of fun having a lot of
activism creative activism but at the
same time really use play or looking at
identity Heritage as a way to explore
collect new forms of collaboration
it's been you know a lot of
um
moments where what can we think about
um in our own city as a way to build new
forms of community building and of
course you know Hong Kong is a very
special place it's highly dense
about 75 percent of the land is actually
um Countryside in green so everything's
kind of condensed in that 20 25 28 of
urban density and how do we then connect
the community to have a role one of the
biggest pilot projects I really had a
humbling opportunity to be involved and
I think this is the pivotal point point
for me in 2009 as a younger architect
curator
to have the potential to be commissioned
by the government different parties to
curate and Lead curate the 2009 Hong
Kong Shenzhen by city benali of urbanism
architecture in Hong Kong I came up with
this
theme called
which is City mobilization how do you
involve the community especially when
there are a lot of huge pieces of land
that were empty or reclaimed how do you
build and re-green or rethink our city
this is the West County Cultural
District very dear project we were given
the opportunity for three months
activation
to think about participation social
sustainability we wanted to activate the
land with our community and participate
with debates dialogues we built the
first paper two Pavilion with shiguruban
in 2009 to host open discussions very
difficult questions about the future of
the city we involved elderly to come on
board to really question their expertise
too and their accessibility with these
activations we hosted 400 you know
students to come build and participate
and also micro farms and this is
actually quite seminal realizing how our
city shapes our behavior and how our
behavior is being shaped by a city we
produce this Eco Farm
with the Federation of youth group and
not a non-frofit organization and when
the children arrived in the site with
their parents they had never touched
soil they also you can see the parents
getting really fearful spraying
antibacterial this is 2009 not knowing
how to grow your own plants or
understanding you know basic human
behavioral Necessities so this was a
really interesting trigger point to
think about
how do we create activation intervention
tactics to communicate the urgency of a
city through play and creativity we had
designers and Architects come challenge
um you know how could you bring about
Urban and nature together so this was
Casey Wong on the left this is called
two Wongs going out to sea and we had to
challenge
um how could we launch boats in the the
sea to encourage new debates on living
in nature and what was fascinating with
this is we found a loophole of you can
put anything in the harbor if it's under
three horsepower and this created this
huge kind of media sensation of what is
what is the role of architecture policy
design to engage our community so fast
forward
we know the foundation's been very
active in shaping a lot of communities
and culture and research abilities and
we were one of the first non-profits to
really believe in the kind of cultural
transformation so not sustainability in
terms of sustainability in the kind of
green Matrix but really the social
aspiration of our culture of the
community
um so we've been doing a lot of
Fellowship research Partnerships we've
been uncovering the beauty of archives
relief funding research grantees and
mentees to participate not only just
physically but also through granting
programs so it's really been a long
journey since then and although there's
academic rigor needed there's a lot of
really powerful narratives and stories
of Architects archive drawings really
thinking about the role of
building our culture and as we build
more and more there are a lot of
projects and modern architecture that's
being destroyed or demolished and how do
we regain our role as a foundational
architecture role to communicate the
preciousness of the cityscape
so that's a quick background
and maybe just to think about design
trust future Studio
um this is a very very unique special
program
looking at how we are continuously
learning contiguously changing mindset
through the voices of emerging young
designer and talent and to match them
with experts but then the experts and
mentors also become mentees potentially
and also are given Breeze where they can
challenge
and also participate in this city so
2017 we we started with small is
Meaningful just as a testing point and
looking at what is the future of living
if we are living in smaller and smaller
spaces it used to be called micro
Apartments now it's nano
what are we doing beyond our homes so as
a very simple question
we curated and brought together four
teams looking at different issues but
the brief was how do you create your own
Park we had really amazing mentors come
on board international local
and someone on the right who did the two
Wongs out to sea also as a role model
how do you find those role models to
transform young designers and architects
Stanley Wong on the on the left with the
spectacles
um created all the posters for In the
Mood for Love Juan Kawaii he spends 30
percent of his life as a Buddhist
philosopher and 30 on his commercial
world and 30 giving back so we didn't
only want to find mentors in terms of
Designing ability but also designing
mindset and participation on how you as
a human being can also transform careers
we also selected Gary Chang who's our
famous interior architect in Hong Kong
who's been living in the same 32 square
meter apartment for the last 45 years
and he tests it as like an engagement of
transformation it could be a library it
could be a place for students it's a
place for his bar his CD collection but
is transformed as a test on using the
most minimal space to for Maximum Impact
and along the way this journey we
started to attract the policy makers the
government members because of the
interventions and activations of how do
we create spaces for the city because
there are really not that many
pocket parks and micro parts that are
developed in a way for the community
um and you know we were looking at skip
Park construction
um uh Depot pieces as mobile parks and
what you realize is you know access to
public space is a basic human right and
um there are about a thousand eight
hundred public parks in Hong Kong
ranging from as small as 44 square
meters all the way to 2000 or more and
um they're very not designed in a way
that gives human dignity and also social
aspiration play Risk taking so we did a
lot of these really activistic
intervention tactics
stitching together and questioning what
is the smallest park bench you can hack
hang off a railing and this started to
think make us realize or the community
realize we need to really think about
our public realm a public space and if
we don't is the future going to be Uber
delivery or future delivery of parks to
your home
and you know throughout time what was
amazing is just the process of piloting
access intervention we then had this
really amazing opportunity in 2018
right before all the extraordinary you
know activities that we face as a city
to the recent pandemic a very
open-minded discussion on what is play
so we developed the Nyx version of plays
for the people a design trust feature
Studio on what is the future of micro
parks in Hong Kong
and how do we commit ourselves along
this journey to change career paths for
young designers opportunity how do you
change the mindset of government parties
policy makers and promote really
exciting discourse and exchanges within
government with outside of government
and a very open collaborative process so
I'm I'm humbly honored it's not been an
easy process because it's also utilizing
creative bureaucracy models it's also
looking at
micro Park Network that potentially
could be designed by the people and for
the people and that was one of our
biggest Ambitions was not to just look
at big International
contacts but with a city as a laboratory
and over time we were
had a very honest discussion with
different members of the community
and we were allowed to shortlist some
sites and selected four amazing sites
within the fabric of Hong Kong four
different types of typologies
um ranging from really really different
districts and a very underprivileged
communities and activate them in new
ways so each Park whether it's sitting
out area it's within a courtyard space
surrounded by subdivided flats or at
spaces within infill sites or Corner
sites that are underutilized we were
able to re-transform and look at this as
a community and I'm just saying it's not
so much about the process itself of
Designing the end game it was designing
relationships so one of my interests is
to build community platforms that bring
experts you know even Richard Hazel came
on as a advisory member for workshops we
had Liz Dilla come on board from sharing
on The High Line we will also be able to
bring a lot of young designers and
architects in different
multi-disciplinary teams so graphic
designer working with a social designer
with an architect an architect working
with a industrial product graphic
designer along the way and curate those
experiences actively in a very open crit
format
so perhaps as an architecture training
that allowed us to understand the power
of education and the role of
architecture and the multi-disciplinary
nature and stakeholder management
allowed us to really build new types of
innovation so it's been really
fascinating journey I know I don't have
too much time but bringing the community
along from the beginning as an active
live studio
testing new types of playgrounds
inclusive playgrounds
there there's honestly there's not that
many parks in Hong Kong that actually
look at it from a universal access
standpoint we also were able to test a
lot of
prototypes and in the site itself use
the physical prototypes as a way to
engage the community directly to give us
feedback we also had amazing developers
come on board to offer free venues for
site engagement there was a lot of
concern groups a lot of fighting a lot
of debating
but what I realized is the power of a
model the power of drawings to visualize
and communicate is really an
extraordinary method and
opportunity for us to work together to
shape the city so K this young designer
graduated from one of the universities
it was 2015
very talented was already
we could see she had a really special
unique talent on engagement so we
brought her in and what was amazing
through this process is she worked with
a lot of communities that were
surrounded above and living in very
tight
um
subdivided flats
and when we did open the park in 2021
this eight-year-old girl who
participated in the workshop
was saying and really proud to see her
little models
produced into reality with the community
and this is the mindset we're thinking
of touching like how does architecture
really touch the grassroot community but
at the same time change government
policy and we were very pleased with
this process to enable the government
parties to commit to 170 Place spaces to
be engaging the community in the next
five years
these shots are from a very difficult
time that we all face during the
pandemic and also pre-pandemic a lot of
new ways of activation and hybrid
designing with the community and with
the kind of you know before
uh site visit the engagement of
community the renderings to the reality
about 150 meetings in the last two years
three years to to produce but the
Breakthrough is as simple as using
Graphics to enliven the community to
create very informal play spaces
merry-go-rounds that were often seen as
a way to encourage play and risk taking
for for for young children the elderly
in one side of the park
multi-generational safety you know
looking at their Community within itself
and also able to
re-energize underserved communities and
and give them dignified places so the
last few slides
um just to share it's these
multi-disciplinary teams my role is not
so much an architect or a curator but a
facilitator in the process we can't do
what we do without men any layers of
expertise coming together and this is
sort of a takeaway in Impact if a
project is seen successful it it really
is because of the rigor of that process
in itself and the outcome we're still
learning there's a lot of materials
whether they could be reconstituted with
strongest sense of grading without
deterioration or is there other ways of
improving playground spaces that give
uniqueness to that Community there's
many many questions we are still working
on but what's aspirational and hopeful
and optimistic is how architecture
urbanism Graphics The Willpower of
multi-disciplinary teams the
understanding of our you know serious
rigorous observation on how we live or
utilize in a city and taking action to
give dignified seating and
um really respect the community as along
the way and add more Greenery this pink
Park was very controversial because it
was in a former red light district and
so there was a lot of pushback about
just color in itself engendering a
different way of looking
but what was amazing with this
particular team after bringing them to
New York's Bryant Park which was in the
80s crime infested had um you know
really you know difficult kind of
situation of drug abuse very similar
this area had the similar kind of
notations but it was a public private
partnership model
and using Color to re-energize and study
psychology we were looking at studies of
how prison cells if you paint them pink
it decriminalizes activity but pink also
celebrates love and passion and it was
also squid Game season so this park
became this really odd space of bringing
layers of Halloween costumes we had old
aunties coming from different districts
to see because pink became this
fashionistas Haven so we can read into
our spaces but it also should be as open
and diverse to build sort of
human humanizing spaces so I'll end here
it's been massively challenging I also
very lucky to have um a lot of different
types of communities that come test with
us play chess there's a lot of press
media we have been very lucky to
communicate it was on CNN very recently
with Hong Kong's reputation right now it
was actually a really pivotal moment
last September when we opened more parks
for the community to celebrate
optimism and hope doing such really
extraordinary times we face but also see
the hopefulness of how design
prototyping
looking at under flyover spaces as a
global discussion on how lighting can
transform safety and access to
really beautiful
dignified areas and also one of our
biggest challenge now is to restore and
imprint Our Heritage so this site is
really powerful I welcome you to come
visit we've just soft launched this but
we want to celebrate from 1840s all the
way to 1984 this particular area had a
lot of cultural invigoration films were
made a lot of bamboo steamers like old
seafoodcraft was born in this area
there's a lot of really amazing stories
about
regeneration and revitalization through
times from the British colony all the
way to how Hong Kong is a special
administrative region so there's a lot
of things to talk about how public space
needs dialogue narrative history
Community participation and I'm really
excited our next Park is hopefully going
to be completed by April and this one
will be very special because it's
actually created with local Craftsmen
and this is quite novel because all the
parks and procurement process in Hong
Kong is you know the specifications are
quite strict but we were able to really
utilize the testing and have Seafoods
who are making these beautiful old
chopping boards to create the signage
there's amazing 65 or 80 80 long year
history of
these copper makers that are actually
involved in making the park elements
together so
um just just to conclude I know my
time's up but just to thank you so much
I've learned a lot in the last week we
all have similar values to make change
and reclaim the role of architecture
design that can make a change but it's
also this notion of generosity of spirit
and how we collectively pull our
resources
and to kind of better our region and
aspiration so thank you for having me
[Applause]
thank you very much Marissa for sharing
about your projects in Hong Kong I
especially love how the simple use or
the change of color can evoke so much
change so finally we do have architect
Chan Su Kyan founding principle and
design director of scda architect
Singapore as well as jury chair of the
architecture panel architect John is a
founding principal and design director
of scda a design studio seamlessly
integrating architecture interior design
landscape architecture as well as
product design to create holistic
spatial experiences so scda has offices
in Singapore Shanghai and New York and
the firm has designed over 70 locations
across Asia Africa Europe Oceania and
North America
architect John was the inaugural
recipient of the president's design
award and the recipient of three
American Institute of Architects
International and the AIA New York
awards for architecture as well as three
Royal Institute of British Architects
International prizes and now in Chicago
athenium Awards The Works of scda have
been published extensively and presented
at the Venice finale
John has been featured at the Salona de
Mobley for product design for
established Italian Brands poliform and
Christina so right now I'd like to
introduce and invite architect chant
please
[Applause]
good morning
eight years ago I was here also
presenting on the Forum
and the topics that we talked about has
shifted so much so for this particular
forum I thought about what I could
contribute and one of the things that I
thought I could share was some of the
things that actually happened to me on a
personal level right the power of
climate change
as Architects sometimes we work in silos
and we may be a bit detached on what's
happening but this is one of the most
Pleasant beautiful site in Wyoming in
2020 in the middle of the lockdown all
of us dream of an escape so I was
looking for a site to build a hotel for
myself in the cat skills and I
transformed this
and I bought it sight unseen right and
and and and and it was only after a year
later the at my first opportunity I was
there surveying the site they did not
disappoint it was calm he was beautiful
and of course as an architect my first
instinct is what do you want to build
there and how do I use this opportunity
to test up all the ideas I have to build
sustainably to be off-grade to use the
local Stone to crush to engage the
community the list went on and on and on
but our ideas and our plans do not
always go as planned right
so the design that you see on the left
try to fit in
and we engaged the planners and they
were happy that we're there and we
checked all the boxes there was a bridge
that's already there
and I spoke to our jury chair in your
panel on how I should strengthen it and
when to strengthen it I did the water
test
to do everything that I need to do to be
as polite a building as possible
and we use sim skill to study win
which I can imagine wins of 150 40 miles
an hour at the peak and and then solar
as well to really understand
the impact each room and where to put
the solar panels
to actually maximize okay
so this is all good this is all good
but nature has its own plans
right
first of all when we this is what
happened right and we worked with the
science we worked with what we really
want to do
but nature has its own plans so this
this was the design that I came up with
the plan was to engage a community to
have a luxury hotel and I feel like the
word luxury need not be a bad word for
Architects because even to engage with
climate change you need private Finance
you need family offices you need the
livers of power and cooperation okay
it was a wave to to really look at
nature and be a polite neighbor okay
but plans change a week before the
community hearing investigated reporter
uh Googled and found out about this job
found out that we had another hotel in
Bali there was also luxury
and unfortunately at that time Kanye
West bought a
five six hundred hectare side close to
this that's bad that's really bad right
so the result of it was a community
hearing and thumbs down uh
plus I really did not feel welcome in
Bali I felt welcome
you know in Wyoming you can expose your
weapons so in the town hearing it was
quite a cultural experience
you know if you look at the little uh
slide on the lower right you can see the
room filled with
people not from here
but I understand because there are
Wildlife Conservation groups Golden
Eagle was two miles away so I had to
move my building two miles away and
moved my building right and then we had
found artifacts from Native American so
so we got a scale down permit to build
three Ranch houses
and really I just wanted to do something
that was low impact so I created my own
brief of uh artists in Residence Studio
the gallery and then promote native
artists I just want to make something
and experiment to be totally off-brained
and and so the form was generated
by some of the wind parents
okay and it was at a time where I really
wanted my building to react climatically
to real science and not just rely on
reusing material or
cross ventilation and planting more
trees on the facade this is not what I
wanted to do but then the plan change
again in June 13 we had the one in 500
year flood in the yellow stones
and this was this was the ferocity of
the river look I saw the slides I saw
the video at CNN and Al Jazeera on
Pakistan one third of the country of
London I saw that the climate in Beijing
in China and in Europe above 40 degrees
but then
the bridge was no more I had no Bridge
I had no sight
um and also I was actually arguing to be
closer to the floodplain because in the
last 100 years has never been a real
flood and the river was so calm but this
is a personal revelation okay
but this is not new uh three weeks ago I
was in Siem rib and I wanted to take a
trip down the river the Malcolm the
Mekong Delta always floods
and electronic sublet people are
adapting that these people lived with
tidal ships of
30 feet water 30 feet but then they
built lightly and they accept the
condition
so it really shows resiliency
adaptability
and then I heard from my guide the
government's got built Lake walls you
know I was concerned because it's melt
adaptability you know you build the
walls it could really impact other areas
but this is where I think
as professionals as architect we need to
cross adapt and talk to people in other
disciplines as well okay
um I saw the community I saw
a market I saw kids going to school I
saw a funeral
all within this low impact unplanned
area and they've existed for a long time
right
but they are resilient
they're very resilient and they deliver
this every year okay
and they tried the meat again
so these are all the things that are
happening real crisis but I think it's
Architects were a bit detached we're
still looking at our micro sites and
trying to think oh what can we do to
reduce our impact on our one hectare
site
okay
so this is where I I go back to Wyoming
and I realized that oh maybe I shouldn't
put anything but I was determined to put
something you know
I just keep scaling down it's getting
smaller so so this one okay light
footprint I don't even need a permit
if I I would and and yeah so really I I
created something called tender which is
actually outside the Ura we have time to
have a look but in your area we are
quite shaded so sometimes the air
condition doesn't come on
there's no sound because all my videos
have
really
really quickly
but it's interesting
how eight years between pdas at that
time the speakers of Richard Rogers it
was Richard Rogers Kerry Hill and all
the star Architects but today I'm glad
that we have other people from other
disciplines speaking
um
but this was this was quite recent the
last three four years
no
um well continue talking right wow
technology kind of like throw off the
Rhythm
okay what do Architects do we work in
silos including me
uh I will talk forward a little bit I I
try these days consciously to talk to
non-architects about climate you know
Chief sustainability officers or
corporations people who are more
activists just because I feel like
what we know and what we're doing has
such little impact we need to plug in
what else do I say okay
but Architects are really concerned we
have a heart
but we huddled together and we we talk
within our disciplines
there was a statistic uh very few
Architects are invited or attend climate
conferences
maybe less than
like 0.1 of a percent but Architects do
try and and mitigate but there's another
way I think sometimes we can help
outside of our perform our own
profession
yes
all right so
after the intermission what I was saying
was what I was saying was that I tried
to scale down
and the experiment took a little while I
built a prototype first in in Bali and
and now one in Singapore
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so this was
an opportunity rethink the hospitality
industry because we also work with the
luxury brands
if there could be another brand that we
can rethink to experience experiences
and nature
okay so these
This Is Us
we we are serious and we convene and we
talk
I've been in some of these
and we talk about the problems but we
try to solve it on our own with
architectural means
and on our own
we tend to have Bolder Big Ideas we tend
to
to pick up on things like reusing
materials and and so on and so forth
which I think the discussion has to go
beyond that
right but there are already many
organizations that are tapped in and
doing the same thing and they they
include all the disciplines and The
Architects among them too
this is a real statistic
some say 21 some say a bit more but
participation very little right how can
we be taken seriously if not plugged
into a larger
dialogue that's going on okay
and globally while climate change is a
global problem there's also local things
we can do U.N programs have been set up
right they they set and agendas even if
we can't go we can still be in touch
the intergovernment panel on climate
change is important one because you you
need to vet what is the latest science
what is real and what's not real
and even as Architects their
architecture professions have organized
about commitment to 1.5 degrees by 2030
the Paris Accord
so a lot of firms have pledged to do
that at least in terms of intention we
are committed
and these goals have been adopted widely
okay
but beyond that on a local level what
can we do we can do small things one
million trees is one of them our company
has pledged a thousand trees which is
actually three hundred thousand dollars
and we are not there yet we only barely
thirty thousand but we are getting them
we're getting our staff to include our
vendors and contractors to pledge we
hope to do that within a year
and these are adopted just to to kind of
imbue Consciousness into our own
practice okay and we are we are the
global design partner with parlay for
oceans oceans and marine life
conservation in New York for the several
years already
um
but it's not just environment it's
social and cultural and some of our
speakers has spoken about and I would
like to just illustrate one project
where I think that has driven the design
this project is in Bali Bali himself is
magical and allows for you to do these
things okay
um in 2010 we were certified Earth check
and there was a long time before the
climate dialogue
is is as prevalent as today okay
and in 21 we had the change maker award
and sustainability leader finalists for
which also but this was what it was when
I acquired the site in 26 Petty Fields
as we know pedophiles are not really
good deforested and maintained emissions
um and it's all cut down right so this
is uh what it was
and this is what it is because there's
spider programs with Hotel there the
reforesting uh the establishing the
nursery for local Foreigner and also
using the local phone at the mid ticket
against erosion this part of the program
that started a long time ago
so you can see the sides of the erosion
is some wood and some eye Premiere
plants further up the river
there was big erosion and we built a
small stripe of C1 we realized that it
just pushes the problem somewhere else
right and even my personal experience in
Penang I had an apartment overlooking
the ocean in Garnier drive there was a
project reclaiming just up and all of a
sudden the beach was gone
it became the tight we see that okay so
this is a site plan of how it was
to start Bali is full of religious
ceremony it's a very integrated daily
into the spirituality so when we started
I was advised that in order for this
hotel to succeed you need to build
temples and do 11 and we Engage The the
priests of the village to determine
where the temple should be big and small
so this is where he walked and
disappointed
and then there was also irrigation
because there was a working peripheral
inside we had to speak to irrigation
head there's a lot of uh built-in
cultural rules that we respected
including access to Temples through the
hotel
and I think all that initiative was
looked at as constraints constraints but
in the end I think working with the
constraints actually helped ground the
hotel in its placemaking
and then we live in harmony with the
surrounding Community there's no way I
was going to be able to live
peacefully in Wyoming so we are not
doing anything we're just putting a few
tenders you know
there's no point in there when you're
not welcome you know um
so they leave blessings in the hotel
we're actually engaged full time on our
staff
to priests to bless the staff and to
bless the temples
but this is what Architects do and say
we use local materials we did that also
this is within
four kilometers from the site as Batu
Paras we use it extensively
the local craft of terracotta we use it
extensively as well
and then we try to Source the main
staple from the agricultural Community
around the hotel
and then for the spices as part of the
guest experience we have them
instead of importing them
we we rainwater Harvest and we bought
all our own water there's no plastics
and 85 percent on staff are from the
village which means you don't need to
commute
they come by motorcycles walk or cycle
and a lot of them have been there since
the very beginning
gray water recycling this is a inspector
from Elf check
to to certify for us
so I believe that we cannot just claim
and greenwash we have to be
science-based and we have to hold up to
what we claim
15 of the total development only is
climate control
so while I do these things I believe
that we can still uphold design quality
which is what our our conversations was
about it has to be both
we have to be responsible and still our
whole design right
this is the bar
and even in the spa it's naturally
ventilated you see rain coming down
and it's very very connected except for
the spa rooms they're open
the restaurant is open it's designed
with a low hanging rain canopy and
natural ventilation through the slots at
the top
so
luxury did not be a villain luxury will
be bad will be not necessarily discount
I I we charge an entry which I argued
and I shortlisted it because it it had a
luxury brand but it was a good project
by Kerry Hill but because the brand was
luxurious great scouted I think most of
our jurors discounted it
but I allowed them to come and present
to at least give them a chance to see
what they're trying to do Luxury is here
to stay let's not kid ourselves we need
to engage them okay
I no doubt our our clientele is also
quite high level but but some of these
people do appreciate and they only visit
hotels who are more sustainable it's
gotten to a level where they too won't
be a part of it okay
Community engagement is big
[Music]
foreign
I think we can try to do parallel
initiatives
to try and kind of offset part of what
we do
and we we need to expand what we
discussed and we talked about we need to
engage more people
and we need to break away from what
Architects always do which is to be
siled and to also exist a very high
level when actually humanitarian crisis
is happening at such amazing rate
we need to be a part of that even though
it's not architecturally involved we
need to be active
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much architect John for
sharing I actually like to invite you
back over to the front
and take a seat over here instead
because right now we're going to be
moving on to the question and answer
segment so hopefully everybody has found
this morning sharing very insightful I
also like to invite the rest of our
panel members the kindly join architect
Chan in France so for our speakers
and of course moderating this session
would be Dr josean rezai Global design
director of ramble and founding director
of web structures Singapore he is also
the jury chair of the design panel a
little bit more about Dr rezai he is an
engineer a design Visionary and an
educator so one of the initiators of the
concept of fusion engineering he is the
first and only engineer to receive the
coveted PDA designer of the year he's
very passionate about the process of
advanced computational design and a
holistic approach to architecture
structure and environment
Jose's high profile contributions to
Industry this course include his
involvement in the master jury for the
Aga Khan award for architecture and his
Service as a jury member for the PDA
ever since 2017. so to our audience
again please take this opportunity to
ask any questions you might have during
this q a segment this one of the only
chances you have you may scan the QR
code on the screen right now to actually
submit your questions and without
further Ado it is my pleasure to invite
Dr josean rezai to kick-start the panel
discussion so speakers please yes thank
you thank you for that presentation and
welcome everybody good morning
and I was just told that I I looked more
handsome in in person than my photograph
so so starting with a bit of beautiful
compliment so I'll be asking you the
most
easiest of the questions because of that
compliment but I I came here prepared
I had all my questions typed
and then uh then I did all these
handwritings while I was sitting there
because I realized all the questions
were beautifully answered by the by the
prolific speakers whom we had so I need
your help please to get engaged and
involved through these things so that I
have some questions to raise in the way
of introduction that we had this
beautiful
and moving introduction by Lee Bay and
Dawn followed with these three highly
formative and insightful presentations
by our speakers
what I picked up the word that I've
written here the part that I can read is
the theme of activism came through even
though excuse me even though our
speakers come from different different
backgrounds at one end of the spectrum
to
um
luxury that that Sue spoke about the
education and social Community
engagement and The beautiful
landscape architecture that we saw from
quash but the the the theme that for me
um bound uh the three presentations
together was was activism and I just
wanted to maybe uh start with the theme
the the the main theme of the day which
is creating a better world through
design as like huge
theme
just a general question how do you
um how do you see design
creating a better world the way that
you're doing through your respective
respective work and maybe while you're
talking about that while we're making a
better world let's accept that it is a
better rule but is it is it good enough
enough I'll be what we're doing is it
good enough to achieve the sustainable
sustainability goals the one and a half
degrees and the things that you all
talked about maybe
we start with coach
thank you
okay
yes
um I think in when we talk about
adaptability I feel that we have to be
the one who adapt
and I think from many
terminology we still adapt nature to us
right like we say yeah adaptability
mitigation but everything's as a
human-centric design
I think we still doing the same thing
just create more terminology
nature-based solution ecobed solution
adaptability for adaptability but I just
feel that we still keeping doing the
same thing and I'm criticized on my work
as well that at some point we have to
serve human needs but in that sense how
can we not adapt nature but adapt
ourselves learn to grow food learn to
teach the younger generation and adapt
from what we have and I guess
um the less human-centric will be the
answer that we are not center of the
universe but do we really
um
put that if
of course in some country will be hit
harder and some would wouldn't be hit
anything from the climate change maybe
they get warmer
maybe they like it better but I just
feel that from us we are an agricultural
country
and majority of the people who is
supposed to serve is actually
um understand that of the basic quality
don't even mention about the Green Space
public per capita we like really high up
that we are lacking in Bangkok so I just
feel that how can
the design change is narrative that is
not solving only one part of to people
and mostly we're trying to
to serve like a top high what we
mentioned luxuries or those who can pay
us but how can we serve those our design
will impact more than just
really focus on those who pay us but
you the design have to be border since
yes thank you
um Marissa you you specifically
mentioned
creative activism in in the more
um and and and the the contrast with the
in the context within which you work uh
compared to coach you know in a in a
sort of uh highly urbanized environment
in Hong Kong and the work that you
showed
um would you like to talk to us a little
bit more about that yeah sure um thank
you
um yeah I mean activism sounds very
radical
um it also seems to be seen as you know
a negative light so maybe maybe we would
say creative
um
collaboration maybe it sounds a little
bit more diplomatic in this context
um I think I think to answer your
question yes sustainability building a
better City in one sense we need to know
more about our own um
values and I think with the last few
years
what we've all faced collectively or in
our own kind of city and culture we
actually realize there's much more to do
and especially with the projects the
micro part projects although we did it
um you know it's been a long journey for
the last decade to build up to that
um you realize more and more the
importance of the public realm for
mental health for well-being there's
this this kind of stigma of
um you know City and Greening but when
it comes to like human behavior and
psychology
that's the most important there's a lot
of stigma there's a lot of um ways
people don't and can't express
themselves but you realize you know
there's a lot of um
issues with say one of the communities
above that was sharing
um you know there's access to technology
that was not spoken of you know children
that had to be on Zoom but had no access
to to joining with the access of
technology to learn or you have parks
that were completely
closed off
um and without that access to to play
run around you realize that kind of
social human value was just being
depreciated or underappreciated so I
think what's been fascinating is this
kind of notion of
um keeping it open mind enough with the
Precision of what can we do with just a
very innocent question and riding on
that openness to
um to build dialogue and activate cities
um
and interventions in a way that kind of
bring
your own perspective into it I think
that that's a model that we're
continuously testing and whether it's
like yes we need to build
um you know allocations of you know
Community ownership of public parks so
people take care of them or could you
actually bring
um you know sustainable like you know
grid off-grid formats it's complex but
if we don't test them by doing improving
um then you can't get the buy-in so I
think I come from it from more of that
angle but in terms of good design or
what is good design I think it's just
basically really looking at um more in
the human condition and it's complex
everyone has their own needs you know
from from developers who want to hit
kpis or bring the largest economic value
but one development is great but what
does it do to gentrification or
the sustainability of an environment of
culture and businesses so it's very
complex
and
um I think it's good to sometimes just
have very precise questions and singular
action to test it and then it becomes
more Regional yeah
thank you so you were you were
encouraging us to get to get engaged
with to cope with International
movements on on climate change etc etc
we have such skills design thinking
systems thinking and we all want to do
good but we are not sure a lot of us
have the opportunity to be plugged in by
for example projects in coach and and I
think
if we look Beyond architecture there are
people who want to fund there's
philanthropy trust there's one Banks
refunds they have millions of dollars
that we don't have
and they're also looking for people like
us so my simple message was not to just
write off because we need to coexist
with private capital and I think there's
a convergence today uh philanthropic and
uh well-heeled families want to do good
even more so but they don't have a forum
and understand that it's beyond what we
can do in the building it's a global
crisis it's unequal Singapore will be
fine we have I think budget 150 billion
to build sea walls but not all countries
can do that so
it's a kind of activism but a way of
actually being able to use our skills to
fulfill ourselves because I realize that
even for a small project like tender I
was able to talk to many companies
so we need that Segway and also
understanding that we don't have as much
power as we think right we need
legislation the levers of power
we need concerted efforts globally and
on our own we can't
true thank you
I have a question is Singapore going to
build a sea wall and then be better off
from the southeast Asia I don't know the
real plan but we have a budget
what about Thailand we don't have much
just for that now I'm just going to add
on like protocol my experience and I see
your statistic like architect was 43 and
I went to cop 26 and it was the first
and was the first landscape and the only
one
not that I'm the only one but this only
one of us who talk about nature-based
solution in the whole conference
and people keep asking for Solutions and
Architects have like designers have but
it's very few of us and from 43 how many
from developed well
OS Indonesia Philippine Thailand Hong
Kong was in there none of us there so
they were making decision without us yes
I want to add to that as well on a
governmental level for example the
Singapore delegation they tend to be in
green Finance or something else they
they also
have not included us so this is one
thing that governments can do also to
expand the idea that Architects can be
part of the solution right
absolutely Architects and designers
yeah
the one one of the one of the themes of
this week's uh uh deliberations for the
for the uh for PDA award was uh of
course the key word was design I think
that's the most most used one the second
most used one I would think was
something like transdisciplinary
something that we saw that actually the
profession the General Industry and the
built environment practitioners are
moving towards being trans disciplined
that there's a mixture of people who are
Architects designers and engineers and
and their landscape designers
Etc and you and you also mentioned that
it is um and the work that I that you
presented for instance uh that uh the
the large and beautiful rooftop Park is
that as you were intimating with us is
questioning is that is that landscape is
that hydrology is that architecture is
it uh public space
um and that that is sort of the the call
for more more moving towards towards
outside our silos a bit of one
discipline as another right what yeah uh
I think Melissa would have a better good
answer for that as one and I just feel
that in reality we fought so hard and in
reality maybe Architects might not be
very happy because they don't have
facade right
which is everything
and all the facade is being turned but
when we were at par when we've been
giving enough space or equally space I
think that's the key and that doesn't
come just like yeah happily and ever
like we laugh and we holding hands each
other
as soon submit or something no it's
actually a lot of
um negotiations budget wise
um trying to have landscape architecture
space in architecture and in engineer
is very tough
and I was surprised through the process
that we've been talking through this
week is it's not very easy here in
Singapore as well
because the craftsmanship or there's a
lot of I'm I'm sorry but there's a lot
of presence of architect and I think we
haven't been and this is like one of
architecture around my nation that we
work at par
what about the other
thousands of thousands Architects that
haven't include
um enough multi-discipline
and I think that's
we kind of fight about the boundary of
Urban Design Architects but a lot at the
top
the world
we perceive as a weak profession
right they don't have us week yeah like
because I don't know why we should have
a seat there right so I just feel that
it's not about who we are architect
landscape or Urban Design or design
thinker or thinking but I just feel that
we have to hold each other strong enough
to really go have a present and fight
for a bigger
um statement okay thank you yeah no no
um I think from from my sort of attitude
is
um there's a respect for everyone's
expertise journey and knowledge
education and you know the idea is to
connect the best of everyone's ability
and you know one one thing I love to
talk about I keep talking about this
ePay Square playground it's it's a real
case study a pilot of ownership with a
collective community so without the
industrial designers access to detail or
without the landscape urbanism elderly
expert who's looking at biophilia and
its presentation without the government
architect knowing all the building codes
and regulations
um and you know I was sitting in these
huge workshops with the head of chief of
fire department to figure out the Eva
access so we could actually break down
barriers there's this kind of
interesting a model of not just
transdisciplinary but other disciplines
where you neglect so where's the
psychologist where is the non-profit
organizer who actually understands the
community
or where is the amazing playground
expert who understands if you build an
extra meter the children will think of
that heightened attitude as taking risk
and therefore bills
understanding of physical cognitive
ability right so there's a lot of
studies a lot of kind of statistics and
knowledge that needs to be imparted for
us to know how to design better so I use
that example of the you know the elderly
man sitting on the ground of one of the
parks he actually likes to lean but we
couldn't design because of the code
regulation
a certain kind of arm chairs for for
there wasn't enough seating so we had to
fight to increase these beautiful like
extended Terrazzo benches so these
individual elderly women or men could
sit could lie could be comfortable
without strict
kind of postures to give them that
ability to relax so it sometimes just
comes down to ergonomics appreciation of
the human body the psychology and I
think you know from a architecture
design standpoint it's kind of this
intellectual curiosity that how do we
build systems where you just begin to
learn continuously learn it's not so
much about
knowledge building it's knowledge
transfer and you know I use the example
of the engineering the the lighting one
we can achieve
um without asking non-profit
organizations and leaders of pearl
hapled Arab to give us like their own
research data
to then present that back to Architects
or Engineers who might not have that
information to empower them so sometimes
you need that kind of
transferent of Sharon openness and uh
the willingness to
try new things great I love that that
idea of the inclusivity including
psychologists historians Etc as part of
the design team as you well because
they're also uh also designers
so I I we're just warming up but we're
I'm told
yeah uh you know I'm told we have only
three three minutes left yeah the the
questions are are in here yes I'm using
some of the questions I'm I'm raising
I'm sort of uh combining the uh the
question there's there are one or two
specific questions like so to you about
the uh the waste plastic collector that
sorry Bali like uh what what happens
with the plastic that is collected the
plastic rice for plastic scheme that you
have recycling plastic is not exactly
that
big an impact is that issue but for us
we see it as a process of Education
because for the villagers uh talking to
them is not as effective as doing
the impact for us is our beaches are
clean because it's all Upstream use of
plastics
um but
dealing with the plastic is our biggest
issue
not all the Plastics are clean and at
the end of the day is not that
sustainable we use the outside
contractor for recycling because we have
no way of really doing it
right okay thank you what uh one
question directly addressed to Marissa
about the success of these pocket parks
that you have that that will obviously
hopefully increase football
and the question is
um
will the pocket Parks create more
footfall of the already crowded urban
areas and creates nuisance to the
residents how do you control or balance
that
well apparently the Hong Kong population
has moved to Singapore
[Laughter]
yeah as a reaction um
change I mean although we started the
you know it's a long process I've been
four to five years with many
complexities in the last few years but
um what what's really interesting is now
it's not so much the success of the
think tank or the project of the
community now it's really building
opening and engaging the neighborhood to
have ownership and have them appreciate
this as part of their community so
there's many things I was just
explaining just just
um you know one of the newest parts that
we opened there's a hardware store owner
who works really hard you know building
materials people go there he started
using the linear nature of the edge of
the park curb as a cutting tool and he
marked five feet ten feet 20 feet to
make it efficient for his own
store use instead of using the measuring
tape he's like drilling so we're
observing we're using now this this kind
of post occupancy study to reflect on
what have we done wrong or are we
leveling the chest tables correctly is
it lighting it was so perfect because we
had originally involved the community
they didn't want light pollution so what
we engineered was the lighting would go
downward to avoid the the residents
problems so although we're mindful we
can't control human behavior whether
it's good or bad
it's this really nice way to saying not
the manicured Parks maybe the best but
if there are these edges and moments
where you feel you could participate and
use it to your own
benefit that's a win-win for all but the
success is only if
um I mean people now are starting to say
oh can we imitate can we mimic this so
I'm not saying the the pink Park should
be everywhere it was coming out of a
process of a context
um but you know now it's more of a next
step is a more district-led Regional
level we've tested this small park but
how could it really emanate and
disseminate knowledge so that other
people can utilize
the public participation process to
involve different communities to to
design their Parks yeah thank you and
one last question which is addressed to
Kosh
the about your Parks the parks are
amazing
but there are still the at localized
locations do you have any Vision
um for a grander plan for the entire
city I presume this might be alluding to
potential you know Park connectors of
the type that you know we have in
Singapore and the overall vision for the
for the city like in Bangkok in this
case
um
I would like to have power connectors
but we don't have enough park yet so
to connect to begin with and I just feel
that that's good questions
but is I think it's not about me or
designer to be naive that you know we
can arrest people and then get put more
parks and that's very difficult to
displace people and I just feel that
for us using design to be positive find
this possibility what we have to to
adapt
and I just feel that
eventually we're gonna sink
and but we're gonna live there
so how would you
be more creative with with with that
things and it doesn't mean that Bangkok
is going to be moved to
to somewhere because people's gonna stay
there and I just feel that the most
important is about how you create
um not only just infrastructure
and infrastructure that doesn't kill
ourselves in the future like our ecology
some experts want to build a sea wall in
the Gulf of Thailand but that's what
does it mean you have no beach you have
no shrimp no more shrimp from Thailand
no
oh my God yes you can't have that right
so many Engineers solutions that we is
it's not about one solution fit all and
we don't want to be like the us we don't
want to be like Singapore not because
because we can't we don't have enough
resource our language is different we
eat differently we we smile differently
we we do think differently the culture
yeah the smell we smell differently I'm
sorry I use this a lot in the judging
like I can't smell your design or
something like that
well the smell was the third most highly
used word over the past few days and all
of it used by her
at the end of the day with two people
and we need help and the only thing that
has helped us from the big disaster or
the unknown nature is Thai people
helping each other
we can't wait for government government
we can help the health at some extent
but how can we build a healthy Community
sustainability is not about just make
the take on your list but it's about how
we can make our Humanity sustain like
here
and I just feel that this system more
strong infrastructure we have to help
each other
yes thank you
um I think we are we have reached the
end of our time we were really enjoying
this this conversation
um I just finished uh by saying the
message that I get we started by with a
sort of theme of activism it seems that
you know one of the things that comes
through is that we actually need to to
do good work meaningful work we probably
need to actually hack the system through
design in a wide remaining within the
system but we need to hack it and and uh
and game it somehow uh to be doing the
the some of the beautiful work that you
saw and and and more of it uh with that
I just uh thank our uh beautiful
speakers and I ask you to to thank
[Applause]
thank you very much Dr rezai and fellow
panelists for the sharing today I
definitely learn a lot about their
overseas projects hopefully we can draw
parallels and learn from their
experiences considering how Singapore is
also a very dense Urban landscape so do
give us a couple of minutes for a
turnover for our next panel session that
will be happening very soon please just
do note that participants who leave
during this time will not be allocated
your CPD points okay so stay here stay
for our next one I'll see you in a bit
so we will be starting our second panel
and we will be exploring on how design
can improve The Human Experience by
bringing about economic transformation
better quality of life and deeper social
connections
so let us welcome Miss Lakshmi
paramaswaran co-founder of the Care lab
in Spain and jury Vice chair of the
design panel less me Paramus Warren is
an international award-winning designer
and Care activist who has been working
in the area of Health and Care for over
two decades in 2008 she co-founded phil4
a specialist design consultancy working
with a right variety of players and
teams within the Health and Care sectors
in different countries such as Singapore
the Netherlands USA UK and Spain let me
use the bus portfolio of projects in
Singapore includes re-envisioning end of
life and hospice care services in
partnership with the lien foundation and
the Ang chinmo foundation collaborating
with design Singapore Council to design
and develop the design thinking and
innovation academy to train the public
and private Health Care sectors and
working with the National Council of
Social Service in Singapore to transform
the social care sector by empowering the
role of caregivers and caregiving So
based on this strategic work she is
currently implementing new care services
and programs together with Partners AWA
rainbow Center and the hospice care
association with that introduction that
has welcome Lakshmi please
[Applause]
hi everyone great to be here thank you I
know you're not allowed to leave but
thank you for staying on
so as my introduction I'm a care
activist and service designer but I just
want to mention especially for this
audience that I also have Way Way Back a
training in structural engineering and
architecture
so uh hopefully
um the sharing this morning resonates
for for you as Architects so I know we
have a big representation here
so we are the Care lab we are a
collaborative network of designers
working to transform care and the way
that we experience care
today I want to share a little bit about
our overall mission and vision we're a
mission-based practice I'm based in
Barcelona but we work internationally
um and I'd like to focus on one out of
our seven different lines of action and
it's this topic of how do we design to
nurture communities of care
and there are a couple of projects that
we currently have running here in
Singapore that I think can illustrate
our approach to this and some of the
results and outcomes and challenges that
are embedded in in such a question
I think it's helpful to maybe start with
a definition
so in the Care lab we think about care
as being made up of compassionate
actions
so small moments interactions between
people let me give you some examples
a mum or a dad waking up in the middle
of the night to feed their child's
warm-up milk and feed their baby
a young man helping an uncle to carry
his shopping and cross the street
could even be a teacher writing a note
of encouragement to a student for the
effort that they've put in
so these are small micro interactions
moments where we notice the other person
and we respond to them this is how we
Define care
and yet what makes care particularly
interesting is that it's a transversal
theme so for many years we focused our
practice only on health care we began
that way
and we expanded the definition to really
look at care more broadly so that cuts
across the silos that cut beautifully
Illustrated for us this morning
it also allows us to use care as a lens
a lens that we can look at on a policy
level
we can look at it on a community level
we can look at it in organizations but
also within families and within each one
of us as individuals
so this Broad and Rich definition is
really what is behind our practice
but here's the tension
when we deliver care
we do so as we manufacture cars
what do I mean by that
so I'm thinking about our Care Systems
right our Healthcare Systems our social
Care Systems our education systems
we approach those with a mindset of
productivity
we think about streamlining
cost saving cost effectiveness
speeding things up
this is what I mean by the factory
metaphor
there's nothing wrong with that there's
nothing wrong with working towards
efficiency but when it comes down to
care and those human interactions that I
described
what ends up happening is all those
qualities those human qualities of care
get lost
and people suffer
so our work at the Care lab is really
focused on bringing back those qualities
of
care to our systems of care
so that we might experience care that is
compassionate
equitable
and proactive
so in the last 10 years I would say
we've been
really obsessed with trying to
understand different models of care and
I want to introduce a framework that we
are currently exploring and playing with
and it's really look exploring this
bandwidth that moves from institutional
based care through to Community Based
care and we have a really strong belief
that a shift towards more
community-based care is
the only way forward if you look across
our societies and our systems they're
buckling under the weight of the
demographic shift that the whole world
is experiencing around aging we're also
staring in the face crises around mental
health these are all huge burden on each
individual society and there is no way
that any government can stem this can
tackle this and so unless we start to
look at how do we move care out from
institutions and into the community I
think there's no way forward in in terms
of a sustainable solution plus within an
institutionalized model and that factory
mindset we're losing the qualities of
care that make it matter for all of us
and so moving to the community is also I
think to link on the last discussion is
also a way for us to tap into that deep
infrastructure of care that we have
between every one of us
so these models and I hope as as
Architects and urban planners you get
excited about this as much as we do the
models over on the left are starting off
looking at kind of a center-based
center-based setup where you have really
the infrastructure the building itself
is where the care is delivered and as we
move towards the right we start to break
that down so you have you know quite
traditional settings of Home Care where
professionals from an institution go out
to people and take care of them in their
homes but you also have and great
examples here in in Singapore we have
the vertical kampong mentioned as an
example of this model which is a
purpose-built community to support
elderly so that they can age in place
but all of this cluster of ideas here on
the right are starting to break down
that institutionalized structure and
actually connect with the community in
very different ways so you have
self-organized Circles of Care where
individuals stay within their homes but
they connect through either digital
platforms or have new roles like
Community coordinators who help to
deliver services that might be needed
all the while people being able to stay
at home
you also have a really interesting model
from
Barcelona called Radars which is a link
up between the community volunteer force
and social services so informal and
formal care services working together to
support people within in this case
within a neighborhood to tackle unwanted
loneliness
and then over on the far right you have
really a disintegration you see there's
absolutely no buildings in that far
right model it's really about activating
a community in this case to be the
example is to be dementia friendly and
dementia aware and to sensitize the
population to be able to live alongside
and normalize persons with dementia to
the point that they truly understand how
to support them in a dignified and
natural way in everyday kind of
interactions
so I want to maybe talk about two
specific models that relate to our work
here in Singapore I'm going to talk
about one project which is over on the
institutionalized care model as a
starting point and looking at how much
you can actually achieve in in terms of
creating communities of care even when
you're within one physical setting and
I'll also talk a little bit about a
project that's somewhere in the middle
of this bandwidth where we're working
with an institution that wants to expand
its services to support people within
the community so its footprint is
enlarging and to look at how to do that
in a graceful and empathic and sensitive
way
so the first project is called care
beyond walls we're working with the
Leanne foundation with AWA with ILO
Architects and with impact
evaluators and and lobbyists trisector
Associates
and so let me introduce you to Mr and
Mrs joyo who live in Ang Mo Kio
um life before dementia looked a little
bit like this that was their home in the
middle here the hdb and they would spend
time in the course in the kopitiam
library and the mosque they're going to
their relatives homes in the local park
this is all before Mr joyo receives a
dementia diagnosis
and so the assumption is
that his life would shrink and basically
the main Journeys that he would take is
between his home and the AWA daycare
center that's in the neighborhood
the point of the project is to actually
maintain those connections and
relationships and routines and rituals
that he and his wife have with the local
community so you see some of the the
lines in green pointing to
interactions between services not only
in the daycare center but that continue
to be within the setting of The the
community and so you have the mosque the
library the coffee tea I'm still playing
a role as he learns to live with
dementia and as the disease progresses
and it's really about an activation and
sensitization of that Community through
building of Partnerships but I'll get
into that in a second
ah oh I'm sorry I just uh these little
icons that popped up is another layer of
the project and it's actually
an element of this ecosystem
um of solutions that has already been
launched in the public domain there was
a phase one of press and media around
this so
the whole vision of the project is to
empower persons with dementia and their
family in a way that they can continue
to contribute within their community so
SF is actually representing a volunteer
Workforce of persons with dementia who
go out to volunteer within the community
so it isn't about just building a
network of support it's also about
empowering them and facilitating them to
continue to contribute in different ways
so this is the part that's actually been
launched at the end of last year and
it's an image from some of the press
that was received
um
are various Partners within animal kill
have been the first to come on board to
collaborate with Awan to extend and
develop these Services together and so
the temple here Dharma muneshwaran
Temple is one of those Partners you also
have Elias Park Primary School or one of
the first early adopters to come in on
the project and Jamiah child care as
well so three three partners and what
this this might look like typical kind
of Outreach that you've seen before but
what's Innovative in this is the
engagement with the temple in this case
and the co-creation of the programming
and activities that people are able to
do and the creation of purposeful work
you know this is not a distraction or an
entertainment they're able to go there
and contribute to the running of the
temple it means that for awas staff the
lady in the T-shirt they are learning
how to forge those sorts of Partnerships
and relationships with the community in
order to also educate them about what it
means to live with dementia and how they
can create a temple that is dementia
friendly for that neighborhood so
there's activation happening on on
multiple levels
let me jump to the next project
um that I mentioned and this is a
project with HCA so the hospice care
Association together with Leanne
foundation and lecco Architects and
we've been looking at the topic of end
of life care for it's come up to 10
years this year and we began that
Journey here in Singapore
and one of the things that's at the core
of our practice and our approach to
palliative care and how to support
people and families at the end of life
is to zoom in and understand the
conversation at the end of life so what
you see here are some examples from
hca's New Day hospice it's called Oasis
at outram it's within the outram
community hospital and these are
conversation tools and a conversation
room
so this is typically in healthcare
called a consultation room right
we're trying to make a shift from
consultation that is transactional and
process to conversation that is
relational and creates an entirely
different space for connecting with
people especially at this
challenging and confronting moment in
their life so within the conversation
room you see here the staff store a
number of different tools and triggers
this is a solution called The Wheel of
Life that was co-developed with medical
social workers co-developed through the
pandemic by the way VIA Zoom making
prototypes going back and forth and it's
a very very simple tool with sliders
that allow people to present and
represent how they're feeling about
different aspects of their life about
relationships with family about pain
physical pain
stress Financial worries we identified
some of the top kind of parameters you
know the considerations that people
might be facing and so the I think the
trick here is that this doesn't come
with a training manual this is a tool
that social workers are able to use when
they feel appropriate it works for some
patients more easily than for others
it's it's a support it's a prompt for
unpacking and getting to reveal some of
the the main issues and needs of their
clients
but it's not just patients that need
support
organizations that are interested in HCA
are in transforming their entire culture
of care also need to look at how they
support their own care teams so this is
a concept called Munch and grow and the
idea is that teams take a Munch break we
love to makan right so they take a break
to have lunch and to eat together but
while eating these cards again trigger
them prompt them to bring up topics they
may be struggling with so it starts to
create a safe space around that ritual
of eating together and with a set of
cards that allow them to highlight and
celebrate actually some of the
achievements they've had as a team could
be something very very small but just
allow them to start to talk to one
another and support one another in new
ways because if you don't have a team
that is caring for each other then you
deplete the resources of being able to
care for clients and for families so the
idea behind Oasis is that it's a space
for personal growth for everyone
professionals families but also the
volunteers that are coming in to to
spend time there
I see that I'm getting close to time
we're almost there aside from these
service design elements tools and and
rituals that have been developed we're
very conscious of how this service
experience is sustained and so one of
the parts of the work was actually to
co-create new job descriptions within
the care team that will be able to carry
forward know some of these new behaviors
and practices so the team ninja is a new
role that is actually there to link and
facilitate some of those team caring
practices that I mentioned first time in
the sector first time in my experience
anywhere in the world HCA now have a
service experience officer which in
long-term care is kind of unheard of
we've heard about it in retail in
Hospitality they are experimenting with
the best way to bring that into their
capabilities you have social animators
and story vitalize which are dedicated
roles that are there to activate and
engage you know them the clients and the
families and to actually be able to work
on that level of conversation in in a
new way
one story as we were wrapping up this
project
um we were getting ready to say farewell
to the team and we kind of finished our
work when the medical director asked us
if we wouldn't mind staying with them
for another two years
why was that so I picked this image
because this is the area inside of Oasis
where they they have a garden a
greenhouse and we discovered a new role
that we need to play as designers as
gardeners it's just because I want to be
with Koch and and I really want to be a
landscape architect but um no but truly
it's this idea of of gardening of
nurturing and accompanying in Spanish we
say a company to walk with people so
over the next two years this is what
we're doing we are walking with them we
are coaching the leadership we are
coaching the service experience team and
we're just a shoulder next to them
um to learn but also to be there to
encourage and to be there to provide
support
um in in terms of staying true to the
essence of this work Their Fear was that
despite all of the efforts of the whole
organization to co-create these
Solutions Their Fear was that uh they
might just screw it up if we walked away
and they really wanted this to land and
become the norm and just the way that
they they deliver care so that's the
journey that we're on as the Care lab
I've been mentioning to my fellow jurors
all week is my first time back in
Singapore after the pandemic I really
missed being here we lived here for a
few years we had a studio in Singapore
and in Barcelona and even though we now
don't have a studio here we're really
active
um it's a kind of second home so this is
an image of one of our roles that we see
in Building Bridges between Singapore
and Barcelona bringing moht over to the
city council in Barcelona to see some of
the projects that I just mentioned to
you on the community side and running a
webinar inviting Dr Wong sweet fund to
join us along with other practitioners
to talk about communities of care and
there are so many Amazing Stories here
that need to be heard outside of
Singapore I think that's also part of
our work is to connect those dots and
then just to close a sneak peek because
in the last five years I would say
accelerated by the pandemic we have
been reflecting on our own practice
and realize that we are in the middle of
a shift in fact we've made a shift from
people-centered design to Care Center
design and what we mean by that is that
we are no longer just trying to solve
problems but we're caring about problems
and when you care about problems it
means you go deeper and you stay longer
and in order to see the impact so our
projects are getting longer more complex
many more partners and disciplines
involved and far more impactful
hopefully as a result of that and so I
think as designers and Architects
another element of this and the activism
side of this to Dr rezai's question
earlier is that as a care activist and
practicing Care Center design it's no
longer about responding to a brief it's
about sitting down with your partners
and defining a shared
go
and that's a whole other Dynamic I think
as professionals that we need to learn
how to practice in that way because
that's ultimately what needs to be done
to achieve the results that were the
impact that we're all working for
so with that I just want to end thank
you all for listening and looking
forward to questions
[Applause]
thank you very much Lakshmi for sharing
about your initiatives especially here
in Singapore I want to introduce you our
next speaker and that will be Mr Tim
Colby founder and CEO of eight in
Singapore also during member of the
design panel he has over 30 years in
design and as a leader in Innovation and
branded experience eight ing has worked
with companies such as Apple Virgin
Atlantic Airways Nike Coke null and
Citibank The Firm takes on an
interdisciplinary and holistic approach
working across traditional disciplines
including strategy architecture
exhibition interior design product
Communications and branding so he really
does quite a fair bit many projects have
received International Design Awards and
have been published across Asia Europe
and the US
Tim's 11 Studios and over 200 strategic
designers and business creative connect
across seven time zones in three
continents
graduating with owners in environmental
design from the Arts Center College of
design in Pasadena in 1982. Tim is now a
trustee at his alma mater and serves as
a chairman of the academic Affairs
committee Tim has a book as well it's
called return on experience and it was
published in 2021 to reflect on how all
human value has been the result of
successful design outcomes and that
design is therefore integral to all that
we do can't wait to hear from you Tim
welcome
[Applause]
okay hello everybody it's good to see
you
um I think this has been an
extraordinary experience for us and I
think one of the interesting things
that's coming out of these discussions
is that the disciplines that we're
traditionally trained in are are
evolving pretty rapidly and so uh
hopefully this will give you a little
bit of of perspective on the way that we
think about approaching the design work
that we do
um as was mentioned I I completed a book
a couple years ago called return on
experience and it has been the basis of
uh the things that we've learned working
now 25 years with apple and with many
other other clients but bringing forward
as much as possible the idea of
experience that people have with the
things you design as one of the core
values that you can create
um our our business and it's I think
pretty much in alignment with many of
the things we've heard today
um you see a lot of people who are
interested in in making the world a
better place
um it's a very ambitious thing to to
think about doing you don't know when
you're done and it's and it's difficult
uh to achieve we like to think about
using design as a way to define human
progress that we don't have to make
massive changes we just have to make uh
changes that are are about progressing
the way we're doing things how we're
behaving how we're interacting with the
client with the climate with the
environment Etc
so today I'll talk a little bit about
experience and I'll switch over uh just
to sort of illustrate how that creates
value
um when we talk about designing Human
Experience
um you know how we're trained in school
we look at form we look at finishes we
look at materials we look at all of the
sort of traditional things
um but one of the things that that we've
developed over the years and and
certainly through the work that we did
with
um with Steve Jobs at Apple was the
focus on the outcome the things that
whatever it is that you're producing
what it does for you and so this is a
very important aspect of this finding
the purpose behind your design because
ultimately the form and the finishes are
only going to take us take us so far and
you know it's becoming a much more
complex conversation
the human part is also very important
we've seen many presentations about this
but it's understanding the things that
connect us as people it's also
understanding the things that drive
Behavior the things that make us uh
engage in ways that that we might not
otherwise become Advocates of things
that we think are positive
positive things to be associated with so
it's very important that we introduce
the human part into the the design
and then the third part is just this
idea you know that everybody experiences
more things than you actually understand
and it's and it's this experience that
really ultimately drives Behavior so if
you're looking to improve things if
you're looking to progress things uh you
have the ability to influence people uh
you know in an important way through the
way you think about designing an
experience
um
so um you know what is what is
experience design it's really starting
to express a core set of values that you
stand for and doing it in a way that
people can feel that they can feel it
and understand it and it goes back to
how we connect as individuals it becomes
very important
um when we look for the companies that
we work for
um many many times the CEO will come in
with a great product that they've been
working on creating a differentiated
outcome for ultimately turn around and
and put it into the market by looking at
their peers and emulating the way their
peers do it and so what happens is as as
consumers as people we never see the
difference we never see that so it's
very important to think about
differentiation uh in a way we you know
we use the term beware of best practices
which most Consultants probably don't
tell you but it's about
being something other than everyone else
you don't want to commoditize what
you're doing and you want to focus on on
the opportunities you have to
differentiate
the other part is recognizing that you
know we all know that word of mouth is a
very important thing but a few people
recognize that it's experience that
really drives word of mouth so if you're
not designing the experience you want
people to have then ultimately you're
leaving an opportunity that's that's
untapped and something that could could
help impact your business in a
significant way
mm-hmm
and so when we start to think about
impact obviously in business you know
you start to look at the metrics you
know are we increasing sales do we have
more foot traffic do we have more growth
you know these are these are all kind of
tangible metrics that we want uh to
achieve as uh from a business
perspective but we have to understand
that it's it's
achieving a relationship with with the
people that you're connecting with will
ultimately achieve your your financial
targets
and if you're able to successfully do
this
um you're far more likely to uh you know
to buy or to engage if you're creating a
positive experience you're going to
build greater advocacy and you're also
going to have people forgive you when
you screw up and make a mistake
so the second part then is how do we
think about creating value if we're
taking this this point of view around
experience how does that really matter
how does it really matter to to the
users and to the people providing that
experience
Venn diagram I'm sure that everybody is
fairly familiar with but we've added
sort of the human the viable and the
technical part to this
a a sort of oversimplification but a
better way to understand it in our view
is to say to create value you have to
make things that other people value
that's really what your job should be
and so uh we can we can couch it in in
very complex analog analytical diagrams
But ultimately it's about making that
connection
and the way we think about this is most
most uh most companies will come to us
and and have a list of tactics things
that they either want to achieve or
methodologies that they think we want to
employ and so you typically start at the
tactics level what we like to do is
frame first human outcomes then
determine if you have you can create a
strategy to deliver those outcomes and
then ultimately use the tactics to
deliver the strategy for the outcomes
and the point about this is it's it's
just a a subtle difference but it makes
a huge difference in terms of de-risking
what it is that you're doing a lot of
people talk about well I want to try
this I want to try that but you know
there's a lot of risk involved if you
organize the structure properly the risk
is diminished considerably because the
tactics that you're employing ultimately
will will ladder back up to that to that
outcome that you hope to achieve
so I wanted to use this example this is
something we've been working on for the
past few months
um and uh you're kind of getting a
preview we're going to be uh announcing
the kind of the the finished portion of
this
um in Australia in a couple weeks but I
thought it was helpful when we start to
talk about uh return on experience
because we're dealing with right now a
condition where uh many companies are
struggling with how to go get back to
the office what are we doing why are why
are we doing it and
um you know it's this idea that the
future is more human than you think is
it's it's a nice way of starting
but there are many many factors involved
in this which I will jump into
um this just so you know is the uh the
Apple headquarters in Cupertino we were
brought in after uh Norman Foster had
had designed the building and and it was
in near near completion and
um they asked us apparently the the
staff who were working there were saying
yeah it's a great it's beautiful
building but it doesn't feel like Apple
and every everybody was saying so you
know we really don't want to move you
know they just spend billions of dollars
building this this incredible structure
and so they asked us to come and say how
can we make this like apple and
ultimately what we came back to is one
of the core touch points that people
have with understanding uh apple as a
company uh are the retail stores uh and
so we said you know we need to then
think about let's let's put wood
furniture and let's put wood in the in
the in the building where we can so we
brought wood into the ceilings we did we
did some changes to the furniture
specifications and simply by sort of
carrying that that language uh it
informed the the you know the vast Apple
team that that oh yeah this is an apple
place so it was a huge success which was
which was kind of funny but anyhow
um so if we started tactics and and this
is this is just an example of of that
that value creation engine structure
that I'm talking about if you talk about
tactics you know there's probably a lot
of us in here who have jobs right now
who are looking at reconfiguring the
existing space you know companies are
resizing uh they're looking to move to
lower costs Etc this is a pretty a
pretty common thing
um what are they designing in those
spaces people are looking at you know
how are we increasing relaxation spaces
or outdoor spaces and so these are all
tactical Solutions which may or may not
work but but we're starting with those
in most cases as part of the
conversation
um and so when we when we start to look
at this uh we back it up from from
tactics to strategy and say you know
we're dealing with flex spaces and
hybrid spaces
um you know what are what are we really
doing here
um but it turns out that a majority of
companies don't have a detailed hybrid
work plan in terms of thinking about how
to go back to work and how to
successfully
um deliver an experience for their
employees
so pre-pandemic
current state and what employees are
projecting here in terms in terms of
what the uh the ratios are are fairly
significant
um
so uh let's
the the key Point here is that if we're
starting with with strategy and tactics
it's not going to guarantee that you're
going to have success so so what's
missing we're missing we're missing the
human outcomes and that's ultimately led
to to probably the greatest
transformation in the workforce uh In
Our Lifetime but this this
has also implications of how
disconnected we are between
organizations and and employee uh
understanding this is the reason why
employers think that people are changing
you know we're not they're looking for a
better job they want to improve their
health they want to change their
compensation this is what employees say
they're missing and it's very
interesting that a big part of this is
the human outcome they're not feeling
valued they're not feeling like they
belong to this organization and so that
the type of emphasis that is is
providing the basis is is missing
so when we do the research
you know this is what we're coming up
with not many people are feeling very
engaged they're experiencing a lot of
stress
well-being is being compromised which
relates to their health a lot of people
are feeling burned out and they're
rethinking their their work-life balance
and so this this is all factors that
have led to the great the great
resignation
but what's interesting is the human
outcome here is that they're not feeling
engaged right they're not they're not
experiencing the things that are driving
them to connect with their um with their
employer and with and with the their
their
um
you know they're what is it they're uh
you know where they work
um so these factors then be start to
become factors that are criteria for for
how to think about the design going
forward when we look at the statistics
um uh you know in the next three to six
months we're likely to see a pretty
significant shift
um you know it's it's probably
terrifying in India at this point um in
terms of the of the percentage
um what's what's particularly
interesting is that 70 of c-suite is
looking at changing uh that's a pretty
staggering thing when you think about
the leadership of all of these
organizations uh shifting
um
the ones who are who are
sorry
yeah the ones who are looking at this
both all employees uh by age you start
to you start to break it down and you
look at pandemic hires so there are a
lot of people who are changing jobs and
then want to change again they're not
they're not achieving that satisfaction
and again it's going back to those uh
those experiences that they're having uh
in their in their role
and at the same time companies are
finding it difficult to source for
talent you know where where is the real
talent it's one thing to fill a seat
with with a body but when you're
starting to look for talent the
competition for talent is clearly
increasing
um and you know when we start to look at
it by country uh this has you know this
this research was done with a focus on
on Asia region but it starts to point to
a number of of countries who are
exceeding the global average in in that
regard
so when we look at this we're we're
really looking at millions of dollars
worth of uh HR expenses and Transitions
and uh you know everything that is
ultimately going to become an expense to
the bottom line for companies and we're
also looking at an incredible amount of
dissatisfaction that is is needing to be
addressed through the experience that
people have so these metrics are the
kind of metrics that the businesses will
look at and want want to achieve and
um so while we were doing this work
um we said you know
you know maybe we should look at our
company right what are the things that
that we're doing because we're having
this you know the same problem we have
turnover uh we have change and we find
in the research that you know people at
least in in our studio we look at you
know much greater recognition of the
teams that's something that's very
important becoming more involved in in
what we're doing in terms of the of the
ability to steer and and guide the
company feeling more supported and
informed ultimately more engaged and and
hopefully uh people who will stay
together and work in our teams
so ultimately for us the secret to
creating value is really better Human
Experience and if we're able to do that
we we think we have a much better chance
of creating something that has impact
and and is important
so thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much Tim for sharing and
of course last but not least let us
invite Dr mingtan a founding executive
director at tech for good Institute
Singapore as well as a jury member of
the design panel for our final sharing
so Dr mingtan is they found an executive
director for the tech for good Institute
and she is also concurrently a senior
fellow at the center of governance and
sustainability at the National
University of Singapore her research
interests lie at the intersection of
Technology business and Society
including sustainability as well as
innovation
she was previously the managing director
of IPOs International which supports
Singapore's future growth as a global
Innovation Hub for intellectual property
creation commercialization and
management
prior to that as well Dr Tan was the
head of stewardship for stewardship of
the Como group a Singaporean portfolio
of Lifestyle companies operating in 14
different countries worldwide where a
portfolio covered sustainability brand
and data privacy and in the
not-for-profit space Dr Tan is an
advisor to the Singapore tour board and
serves on the boards of Esplanade
Theaters on the Bay Saint Joseph
institution International and Como
Foundation a very busy person indeed let
us welcome Dr Tan
[Applause]
power off feeling a bit tired now we've
had so many amazing presentations and uh
I don't know I hope I live up to to
everything that you've been hearing
thank you so much for the kind
introduction I have one video so I hope
it works later because it's a really fun
video
um today thank you so much for the kind
introduction
um I do wear many hats today I won't
wear my business hat or my govern
ex-government hat I'm happy to answer
questions on some of those issues later
but I'll talk a little bit about the
tech for good Institute we will start at
just over a year ago we are seed funded
by grab and our mission is to see how we
might leverage the promise of technology
to be able to advance inclusive
Equitable and sustainable growth in
Southeast Asia with the knowledge that
in many cases technology has been a huge
disrupter
in societies and communities so we're
very mindful about that this whole
morning has been about how design can
bring about economic transformation
um better quality of life and deeper
social connections and at the technical
institute we ask exactly those same
questions about technology so I don't
have any great projects to show like Tim
or less or culture or any of these
others here but perhaps what I could
offer some thoughts on you know why we
should care about Tech's role in
realizing these shared goals because we
all want them right and where Tech and
design might perhaps inform one another
in the digital age let me set some
context first
I think the economic transformation part
is quite you know sort of we don't
really need to argue with that so much
every government in the world is looking
at digital transformation as part of
their post covid-19 recovery plans and
by 2030 this region where I call it
southeast Asia six so it's the six major
economies in Southeast Asia the digital
economy is going to grow to a trillion
dollars
more interestingly we have 440 million
digital users and they represent the new
face of the digital economy
southeast Asia has leaped frog
technology very few people come into the
digital world on a laptop for example we
have great mobile penetration mobile
devices account for about two-thirds of
internet traffic in Southeast Asia which
is completely unlike what we call the
first generation uh digital adopters
like the us or in Europe
132 mobile penetration so most people
will have more than one phone and this
you take this into account that you
still have 50 million people in the
region who don't have electricity and
150 million people who don't have access
to uh to the Internet so 132 mobile
penetration is pretty amazing
um and you know I think it was less you
talked about transfers right we think
about the digital economy as a version
vehicle like this is the tech industry
but actually Tech is horizontal because
you have Technologies that's going to
touch every part of our Lives an example
would be digital payments because of the
covet pandemic and people wanting
contactless uh payments Etc one in two
consumers surveyed by the technical good
Institute had adopted
mobile payments or digital payments
ninety percent of them only in the last
two years and interestingly most of them
would say they would continue doing so
in addition to scale I mean these are
really big numbers but I think one of
the other things are just really
interesting is how ubiquitous it all is
we talk about The Human Experience today
and today The Human Experience is also a
technological one technology
intermediates so much of how we live and
I know we have a lot of Architects with
us today I know you're here for your CPD
points
but as you know lady was saying here at
Ura this is the agency that has the
responsibility for making Singapore a
great place to live and work and play
and Architects and Landscape Architects
and urban planners you know you're
responsible for how we move through our
daily lives how we perceive our world
and you know our public spaces really
shape the way we think of ourselves as
communities as people as a society and
even as a nation right but in Southeast
Asia if you you look at the 16 to 24
years old each group they're spending 60
percent of their waking hours online
are we feeling old
right and
you know
have a guess you know how many platforms
are they on how many social media
platforms are they on regularly give me
a guess
five
seven and a half
and these are only social media
platforms so this is not the grab or the
or the you know your Go Jack or your
delivery or Panda these are just a
social media platforms and it's way
above the global average so I would like
to propose that the digital world and
digital platforms are your new town
squares your new public parks
and Within These digital Town squares or
within these new digital public parks
technology is setting the parameters for
human conduct much as what Marissa was
mentioning before because decision by
products designers really shape how we
will express ourselves for example for
example you know we now think that 280
characters is sufficient to express a
fully formed opinion
right and with smartphones and social
media even childhood you know is really
captured in great detail that's viewed
through a screen if you don't take a
picture of it it didn't happen right so
I know I'd ask you can you mind taking a
photograph
how would you use your hands how would
you mind taking a photograph
okay I see some people clicking all
right
maybe the younger ones might do this
if you ask a five-year-old the research
has shown if you say show me how you
take a photograph they do this
you're taking selfies that's the
definition of taking a photograph
so you know Tim mentions experience
drives behavior and their experience is
take you know I have to be the main
character in my video game in my world
and that's their behavior
technology has changed the way we share
information about ourselves you know we
share everything personal communication
has blood between the public and private
spheres but you know really social media
is really just the tip of the iceberg
and I'd like to ask you if you all put
up your hands
right now if you can all put up your
hands
and I'll ask you how many Architects
here have worked with installing
surveillance or building management
systems put down your hands
how many of you might have a smart watch
a Fitbit or any kind of wearable device
put down your hand
how many of you here have a device that
is linked to your phone or that
recognizes any part of your biometric
identification like a thumbprint like
you unlock
your phone put down your hands
and how many of you have a smart TV in
your home where you can actually look at
YouTube or something
that's all of us right so we are
generating huge amounts of personal data
that is being shared and stored and sold
by Third parties and we leave this trail
of digital breadcrumbs through every
device and platform that we are sharing
and therefore our definition of privacy
is changing so those Architects which
are creating private spaces the
definition of privacy human privacy is
changing
and technology is even changing how we
remember
right we take so many photographs we
write so many messages every one of you
during this presentation fantastic as
these conversations have been I'm sure
you've sent one or two WhatsApp messages
all right but how do we retrieve when
there is so much everything gets stashed
up in the cloud
right the way we're curating our own
memories is changing
and I think any of you who has tried to
find an old slack message or an old
WhatsApp message and been really
frustrated about that will remember well
you know we'll kind of empathize so the
designers of digital products and
services have a huge responsibility they
have the ability to make an impact on
The Human Experience as we know it and
now look I could have prepared a really
positive Tech talk that's kind of my job
like you know tech for good Institute
but actually you don't really need me
because
chat GPT will help me write
the perfect talk on why technology
can enable a better Human Experience
now indeed you know technology has
enabled access
right and you know for example we did
some research and seven in ten people
who had had used a digital lending
product
had previously been unable to get
um a loan from A bank or any other
traditional lender
and so for these people these digital
lending consumers their option was to
get a loan from gojek or tokipopedia
previously or or grab or any one of the
fintech providers or a loan shark that's
their option and it's 25 percent
interest with a loan shop so yes
increase access
but does improving The Human Experience
mean easier and more efficient
is that the definition of what a better
Human Experience is how many of you over
the last five days have clicked on
either recommended for you or
you might like this or you know the tick
tock has that for you section how many
of you have clicked anything or a news
feed or your favorite Netflix stream be
honest how many of you have clicked it
it's brilliant right it's super easy
it's super efficient it gives you what I
want you want right I like horror movies
and therefore I get more horror movies I
like to read about cooking and so I get
more news feeds about cooking it's
really efficient and it's really easy
but does this add
and widen our world view and improve
public discourse
if this is the digital Town Square the
digital park that's what it should do
so I'd like to share three observations
on how design is a practice could shape
technology and the discourse around
innovation
now the first is that the design
thinking process and tech product
development actually share a great deal
in common
user-centricity or human centricity I
hope we'll get there Tim a heavy
emphasis on user design research
usability testing the beauty about
digital products is that it's really
easy to do a b testing the way that you
can't with the building necessarily I
mean this makes Tech very effective at
achieving specific results so the
question is to what end is the outcome
the right outcome before you unleash the
superpower so I'll give one example
which was grab
design thinking can help create
opportunity so for example grab really
looked at what its user experience would
look like when they actually found that
they had deaf drivers amongst their
driver pool
and so you know Lesh said don't just
solve the problems care about the
problems first so they had these focus
groups with deaf drivers the designers
and the developers together came to
figure out well what are the Real Pain
points and the top concerns that the
drivers felt was feeling safe in their
own cars communicating with the
passengers and creating a nice
environment in Cabin between drivers and
passengers and because you know you
can't turn around to look when you're
trying to keep your eyes on the road so
this important step was important to
define the problem statement and so then
they iterated on a mix of different
solutions they had a safety dash cam
that was in vehicle for safety
um
the developers uh
disabled the call function it's kind of
small but it says your driver is deaf
and we encourage you to sit in front so
they can communicate with you but also
keep their eyes on the road and they
also disabled the call function if
you're taking uh if you're if you've
accepted a ride from a deaf driver but
automatically it puts you into chat mode
for example and then they created a
series of flip cards such that it was
really easy to communicate with the
driver and so iterations followed and
there were more stakeholders they
partnered with the world Association for
the deaf Federation of the death the
Singapore Association for the deaf and
in other countries the Malaysian
Association for the deaf Etc
and so you know Tim you mentioned
outcomes and how to demonstrate impact
the question is how would you
demonstrate impact on this of course
happy drivers happy passengers but also
deaf drivers expressing that you know
they felt safer in the cars and and in a
more positive environment but also by
inspiring customers
how come it's not moving
can we move this forward
I just press that button
okay never mind I'll just talk about it
where customers saying oh this is
brilliant and let me try and bring this
into my company and this was really
brilliant when the marketing director of
McDonald's Malaysia sat in one of our
cars and now some of these lessons can
be moved to other companies where you
can begin to see a little bit of a kind
of a snowballing effect
of course you know I talked about to
what end to what end are some of these
wonderful you know capabilities aimed at
we also know that when your goal for
example oh my God three minutes so sorry
where my goal is about
um
keeping me on the app for longer they
can be really effective as well you know
if you've ever sort of been on this
infinite scroll an internet Scroll of
content because I am designing to keep
you on my app longer they can be
incredibly
incredibly effective if the goal is to
make me more engaged then the algorithm
will say bring up more controversial
content because that's what gets the ups
and the downs and that's what increases
engagement and that's why if I'm a
teenager on Instagram and I'm looking
for healthy recipes I very quickly can
get going I can sort of get
um directed to eating disorder content
instead it's because it's more
controversial it keeps me on the you
know on the app and so technology or the
process of development is not neutral
and it really can be optimized for the
outcome we choose so we have to be
really careful about the outcomes we
want to
we want to encourage
the second one I'm going to try and be
really fast is for whom a product or
service is being developed and I really
hope this video works if not I can walk
I can talk you through it
the video
it's a soap dispenser
come on
all over all over now the tone of this
was really light but this is a technical
situation right the sensor was
calibrated to recognize a particular
range of shades
this was actually in a Facebook office
so inclusion and removing bias in design
has to be front of mind for everybody
working in every because you know if
you're not a tech designer you're
probably a user or you're a procurer
your client of text and this is really
important as artificial intelligence or
machine learning is really is reliant on
the input data so what you put in
determines what you get out right and in
Singapore we are Multicultural Society
and in our neighborhood of Southeast
Asia where 655 million people 100 ethnic
groups we speak more than a thousand
languages so the available data sets for
Southeast Asia may not be fit for
purpose right and you might say Ming
this is a situation that every industry
has a problem with right every industry
has a problem with multiple languages
that's true but tech companies rely on
scale to be able to be even viable and
what that means is that if I built this
town square I need millions of people in
this town square I'm building one Town
Square for millions of people for me to
be able to make money and so they
basically
align everybody so tech companies
understand this they're trying really
hard to think not just of their current
customers but also their future
customers Google is has this billion you
the next billion users strategy so they
have they're betting on The 3v's Voice
vernacular
as well as video
um but you know it's really interesting
how many of you within the last 24 hours
have typed in a search a search query
anything
one in two Indonesians today search with
voice
so that is the new the new way we're
moving forwards so my question is how
might we improve quality of life but
still find ways to respect and preserve
different ways of life and I don't have
an answer but I'd love to hear from you
I know I'm out of time I'll just very
quickly Dash through a third observation
which is this title series creating a
better world by Design in Tech by Design
is this big Clarion call for values
driven objectives right you know you
hear a lot of stuff about data
protection by Design security by Design
and what does by design mean in this
context it's about being really
intentional thinking about
data protection or cyber security right
at the beginning when you're Building
Product and it's really sort of a sort
of a move away from the initial let's
just move really fast break things try
and prototype something the idea is from
the very start your code something that
protects data is your code something
that makes it cyber secure and over the
last week I've heard some of this
elements or some of this thinking come
up in other fields I think the
Architects think upfront about embodied
carbon Ambitions as emissions as well as
the operating carbon emissions the
product designers have talked about
right at the beginning I'm designing for
manufacturing so that when this lovely
concept ends up
being produced there isn't so much waste
now but in Tech this notion of by Design
is so alluring that it's gone from a
principle
to a corporate very aspirational thing
and it's actually enshrined in law so
the general data protections gdpr
regulation in Europe actually has data
protection by Design enshrined in law in
Singapore and in the Philippines data
protection by Design is actually part of
the guidance from the National Data
protection agencies so I'd love to hear
what this design Community thinks about
the way by Design is being employed and
thinking about it really about risk
mitigation is being employed in a risk
mitigation situation how do you feel
about by Design effectively being
just not as an afterthought or Not by
charts because in the past really all of
these things was came after a disaster
so my question is how can by Design be
more than not as an afterthought last
Light I promise
um you know to sum up Designing
Technology For The Human Experience I
think is really urgent when so much of
The Human Experience is intermediated by
technology and in the digital world
creating a better world by Design it's
not necessarily about easier and more
efficient but empowering and enabling
people in a safe in a transparent and an
inclusive way and you know maybe we
could do this through the design process
if we Define the objectives correctly
embedded in the design of systems so we
don't get a soap dispenser like that so
that they're really fit for purpose for
everyone who is meant to serve and by
Design with intentionality
you know to be able to not just deliver
great functionality but also to uphold
the values that keeps our society strong
and safe and Marissa mentioned that
cities shape our behaviors but our
behaviors can also shape our cities so I
think it's a responsibility not just of
the designers and the developers but
ourselves as users as customers and by
humans Tim you know to actually have
that conversation
because the tech companies are very
responsive to their users and that's the
purpose of my Institute the tech for
good if we don't develop the tech we let
the engineers do that but what we try to
do is to highlight that technology is
inherently values driven and so we want
to create platforms that we can come
together to share and debate and listen
and advocate for our vision first of the
future that we want so that technology
can then enable it thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much Dr Tan I'd like to
invite you to take a seat right at the
front also uh for the rest of our
speakers as well as we'll move on to our
final question and answer segment for
the day so all of our panel members
from the second session if you join Dr
town in front please
and of course moderating this session is
Miss Lisa Chong CEO of the index project
in Denmark as well as you're a member of
the design panel So Lisa here has been
leading the Danish non-profit Foundation
since 2018 working to promote and
mobilize designs that improve life the
foundation is also behind the index
award a prestigious worldwide design
prize focused on sustainable and
impactful Innovation she is responsible
for the organization's Vision strategic
and operational Direction originally
from London Lisa has a blended
background and strategy policy Business
Development and implementation just like
before you will have an opportunity to
ask our panelists any questions so feel
free to scan the QR code that you see on
the screen right now to submit your
questions and without further Ado it is
my pleasure to invite Miss Lisa Chong to
kick-start the panel discussion so Lisa
take it away
hello yes can you hear me
well um thank you so much and thank you
to our panelists fellow jurors not only
has it been a delight actually spending
time these intensively the past three
days I mean we've just been brimming
with new knowledge uh so much
inspiration and and it's a wonderful
privilege to be here in Singapore so
thank you for your attention your time
um I I first of all want to you know
thank you for the the presentations of
the talk I've learned so much just these
past two hours and I really wish that we
had these presentations earlier in in
the week but um it also sets the scene
the context in terms of having
discussion so I really urge you
QR code maybe just um questions because
I could feel there's an energy in the
room uh for conversation so I really
urge uh those questions for the panel
but if I might kick start a
first question
um to Lesh just um just just in terms of
what we heard uh the the focus in terms
of the work that you've been doing
around
uh care and and the caring sort of like
going from a human-centered design to a
Care Center design I mean I thought that
was super eloquent so of course you know
with the demographics and the data where
with growing human needs within the care
sector it does require scaling uh and
and of course being sympathetic to
needing to respond empathically and
responsibly
um
what's your perspective in terms of the
challenges in terms of like scaling the
need because of course the growing
populace that's actually going to need
these care needs and and where are the
opportunities and particularly I would
say addressing to Architects and urban
designers here in the room
great question Keeps Us awake at night
that one
um
sometimes we like to think of it not
only in terms of scaling but using a
different term to talk about spreading
spreading as a way of scaling and I
think the reason for that is we're
trying to and I hope that came across in
my talk we're trying to really connect
people and create these communities of
care that
it's a little bit like the word of mouth
you know we've seen statistics around
word of mouth I think that was Tim
sharing that this idea of this knock-on
effect and a culture change being driven
it's it's really a social movement kind
of a mechanism so I think spreading
somehow feels like the way that we will
reach scale in order to do that and
thinking about the role of designers and
of Architects
we need to put our egos to one side all
of us
and we're really being challenged by
this within our team and within the
conversations with other designers and
practitioners
it isn't about us creating all of these
things to make uh scale you know an
impact happen it's also about letting go
so we're in that bandwidth that I showed
between infrastructure all the way
through to Community
Based models of care
you really move from Hardware
infrastructure the world of The
Architects
um
to software the world of service
designers like us
all the way through to the community
side where I think about human wear
so if we want to make that shift it's
also about designing the conditions for
people and communities to thrive and for
these cultures and behaviors and
attitudes to spread
how do we design the conditions without
designing everything for them
so it's about holding back and learning
you know to not build that building or
to not create that tool or even if you
do to create it as a trigger for a
conversation that you don't control and
you don't design so I think we have to
learn how to design ourselves out from
the picture and provide the conditions
uh for communities to thrive and that
will be how real impact and scale will
be achieved
I love that sort of foregoing the
control and the need to sort of like
um in a way sort of um constantly sort
of build the infrastructure in order to
to carry our duties of care in a way
um there is a question from the audience
just segueing into maybe perhaps your
background and education here in
engineering and architecture uh and and
in in what way and how they seem so
different and contrasting
it was very natural Journey for me
someone said somewhere along this week I
think we were talking about finding your
calling
perhaps it was last night over dinner
[Laughter]
um no you said it right
um about having a job and a career and
then a calling
um I coming from a you know Indian
family there was really no option I
really wanted to be a ballet dancer and
an actress that isn't happening you can
be a lawyer
engineer doctor right anyone familiar
with that so reluctantly I ended up in
engineering but I wanted to to have a
much more creative feel so I ended up in
in our I wanted to do architecture so I
segwayed from Structural Engineering to
architecture and then discovered design
so that was the next chapter and then
through design I discovered insights
research so that was the next chapter
um so I think it's been a process
um innately curious person
um and I've been lucky enough to be able
to choose things that I'm curious to
know more about
um and get excited about and I think
that was a very natural Journey then
from engineering through to becoming a
care activist I think the piece of the
engineering and architecture kind of
training and background is this
appreciation of this scale and approach
to design
um
also the systems thinking and being able
to collaborate as we do with architects
who take a certain Viewpoint uh a
certain scale of viewpoint and to then
contrast and complement that with a
human scale which you see from the
interaction and service design level
when those two can work in harmony then
I think we can really shift things so
really
it's not about disciplines it's about
what you believe in and working together
to achieve that
I'm curious about this conversation
about calling so I mean maybe Tim you
know what was your calling I mean of
course that your your expansive career
and the body of work that you showed and
presented I mean it was also sort of
frightful seeing the data and the
statistics particularly in future of
work
um cases that you showed us I mean so
going from something that's sort of very
bricks and mortar to actually something
that seems very intangible and I think
Guided by the care I mean could you
maybe touch on
yeah I think you know we were talking
about the idea of of taking a posture
which you know you mentioned sort of a
more a more humble way of thinking about
you know who we all are and how we can
contribute but the idea that that you
know many many people maybe start their
their uh edu go from their education to
their to their job and they've achieved
their job so they're they're sort of
happy
um and then they start to progress
within that job and they find that maybe
this is this is a career I can I can
really do this and then ultimately it's
getting to that point where the thing
that you're doing the career that you've
you
the path you've chosen starts to become
your calling it's the it's the reason
why you exist but a big part of that is
rooted in an idea of of everyday
learning the notion that we're
consistently learning every day
um because you know you find you find
that path that's going to lead you to
something that's going to be much more
much more gratifying than what you know
could have mapped out in sort of sort of
a you know having followed what your
parents told you to do in the right way
you know in order to achieve something
so I think it's it's that keeping
keeping the the humility and that we're
all consistently looking at lifelong
learning as an idea you know I ask my
kids every day what did you learn today
because I want them to think that you
know about each day as an opportunity
for learning something
and symbiotically you're learning
through them as well so I mean
absolutely of course
um so question from the audience from
Ming
so um you demonstrated how we transfer
our bias to Tech I mean it was a pretty
alarming case and I mean equally
shocking but you know of course our
reaction
how can Tech help us avoid this
a tech that recognizes bias and avoids
it is it possible
that could do anything you wanted to do
right you have to ask the right
questions and that's why for me the
human is always important because we're
the ones
who are being were able to ask the
question so if we say optimize to remove
buyers
then it will do that but if you say
optimize for efficiency it will do
something else and you know I'll give an
example not specifically about bias but
if you devised a
say in a hospital for a medical record
system and if you devised it for Optimum
efficiency
then you will actually have very rapid
sharing of patient data across all
departments
but if you say and and if you say oh I
want to optimize it for health outcomes
and you will actually be able to share
all of that patient data and to be able
to match and have the algorithms find
connections and matches that maybe even
doctors in specific disciplines may not
see but actually you can see
comorbidities Etc
but if you actually say I want this I
want you to optimize this to protect
patients privacy and data
you actually immediately get a lot of
friction in that process because it
becomes hard
to share data
but you've asked it to optimize for
something so if you go to I don't know
how many of you go to nuh if you go to
the wellness center at nuh and you do
your regular health checks and then you
then have another doctor there they
might ask you the same question again
and it's because for nuh they've
actually said they've optimized the
system to actually sometimes China Wall
patient data unless you've actually
given them permission to do it so it's
all about as I say to what end right is
it's us as humans who actually determine
it and as consumers as patients as users
as customers when no any chief executive
any c Suite is extremely sensitive to
the voice of the customer
no I mean and also in your talk um you
you quoted the sort of Zuckerberg kind
of Mantra of sort of moving fast
breaking things disruption is just about
speed it's Pace but I often think when
when I hear that well once you've broken
the things who are going to fix it
who's going to be the person responsible
for cleaning up the mess and and sort of
you know the concern of course
exponentially when we we move at a rapid
Pace that where technology is taking us
I mean
um thoughts around us responsibility and
and how do we design sort of like a
slower Pace well I'm not a public
servant anymore so I can say right yeah
I I think the big challenge for
governments all over the world is how do
you balance
um keeping Society safe keeping markets
stable and at the same time creating an
enabling environment for Innovation to
thrive and how do you know not clamp
down too much to protect society and yet
still be open to new ways of doing
things and to be able to let Innovation
emerge but I'll give an analogy I I
talked to some
um I listen to some Australian policy
makers and this is a creative team so
how many of you know canva
right it's it's sort of like disrupting
the whole Adobe suite right are you real
you probably hate it right because you
think it's too templated but for many
now they can actually do some basic
design it's fantastic
of those we know canvas an Australian
tech product which not that many people
know about and so this policy maker was
saying I want the tech Australian
um that I want the Australian tech
industry to be known like the Australian
beef industry and like oh my God this is
Tech and agriculture is so far apart I
couldn't see I couldn't see the
connections and she said look
when someone sees Australian beef on the
packet anywhere in the world
they know that the animals were treated
humanely they know that there was a
certain level of care taken in the
amount of what chemicals it was exposed
to what hormones it was exposed to they
know that the
people working in the abattoirs had
protective equipment and were not
working 12 hours a day they know all of
this just by seeing Australian beef
and they want to be able to see
Australian Tech as
Tech that has provenance Tech that
actually is responsible thinks about
inclusive values buyers designing with
security in mind designing with data
protection in mind they have something
called Bose the basic Online safety
expectations I think is the E and and
that's required of any company that is
developing Tech
that is selling Tech in Australia so yes
governments can do it and they can but
it's a really really fine balance
especially for
especially for an industry that's moving
so fast
soon I'm going to come to you Tim
question from the audience
um so you mentioned something like how
do you know when you're done designing
and therefore avoid undecided over
design how do you know in yours
I think you know that yeah it is a good
question I think finding you know when
you're done designing we try to
look at maybe one of the one of the
guidelines for that is that you you
can't add anymore and you can't take
away anymore
that you you've gotten to an essential
need and in a way it's a sustainability
idea right you're you're only using what
you need to achieve the the whatever the
objective of the design is
how do you avoid under design keep
taping stuff away
um you know
um
and I think you know you you want it not
to be and a lot of people confuse that
with being minimal and stylistic and
that sort of thing it's really more
about being essential and I think that
good design has a responsibility to be
essential uh you know as a part of its
um its role
the other thing I would just say is that
um
you know we you know I I would love to
be anyone in this room because most of
you have a lot of your career you're in
the middle of it or or even even uh uh
just beginning but the idea that that
are are the opportunity we have as as
designers and Architects and things is
is actually to to we're the most
comfortable with change and change is
one of the most difficult things that
that people go through whether it's you
know losing a loved one whether it's uh
transition in family or profession what
have you and we should be the best
equipped to help Society manage change
to help move through some of these
things and certainly having the empathy
and the and the the emphasis on the
outcomes and those things is a critical
piece of peace to to do that so as you
design things keep in mind that you also
have this unique unique uh capability
and responsibility
I love that I think I think really um
sort of encapsulated sort of the the
overarching sort of nuances in the
discussions we've had all week
um I think with that our time is out I
want to thank you uh panelists and also
just dear friends and and jurors I think
like just just to kind of round off I
mean what we heard today was really our
Duty and
whether you're an architect a designer I
think ultimately we could we're creators
we're makers we're Builders and we can
be the the change Transformers in in
many ways we have a duty of care and
responsibility uh for Equity we are
first and foremost human we build
humanely for Humanity so I think we have
to sort of
realize where we are in this time and
sort of regardless of what your
professions and where the lines blur and
and and are kind of converging
um we we are here to to safeguard and
Steward this planet uh for for each
other and for our future Generations so
thank you for your patience I I hope you
uh you enjoyed today's talks and thank
you all for your attention
[Applause]
thank you very much Lisa and our fellow
panelists for the panel discussion today
shall we give them another round of
applause please
[Applause]
so with that we have reached the end of
PDA 2023 Juris Forum we hope they have
enjoyed your time over here and taken
away some very insightful points from
our panel of experience design thought
leaders your feedback is very valuable
so please do take some time to complete
the feedback form you can access this
via the QR code shown on screen over
here and of course to our Architects boa
and Sia members who have kindly stayed
until the end of this event please do
fill in the survey form with your
details to qualify for your CPD points
on behalf of design Singapore Council
and the urban Redevelopment Authority my
name is Juliana and I want to thank you
once again for joining us here this
Friday now afternoon have a great
weekend ahead
[Applause]